in an op-ed for the new york times
charles m blow writes we are edging
closer to civil war and a hedge fund
billionaire named ray dalio says
basically the same thing and his
argument was
when a person's cause becomes more
important than the system the system is
in jeopardy and history teaches us that
it's a very um
it's a good point and and i do agree but
there's one big issue that is brought up
in the new york times article that i
i've said before i believe will be a
catalyst for
civil war or i should say it could be i
don't want to be as definitive i
certainly think we're in a cold civil
war which has been stated for years but
this issue is abortion
and they bring up the new york times
other people have brought the same thing
and
he draws
interesting parallels to abolition and
the civil war now there's a lot to
consider here there's a lot to speculate
on and
it's tough to know exactly what will
happen because we all have we all have
that bi says it can't happen here
but i will say this
over the past several years people have
jokingly been like ah tim's talking
about civil war again and yeah
absolutely but it's in the new york
times it's in the hill a princeton
professor has talked about it several
security experts gave interviews to all
these high profile publications so i am
i am a little bit confused as to why
people refuse to engage with the subject
that is overtly mainstream and being
talked about in the largest or i should
say at least the most prominent
publication in the country and now we
have another story that is becoming
explosive on the left they are saying
there is definitive proof now that trump
tried to stage a military coup because
rumor was a white house official was
saying the national guard was going to
be called in to protect trump supporters
during the insurrection
now i think of course the establishment
view on this is it's insane
but that doesn't matter it doesn't
matter what you or i think about their
view of january 6 what matters is they
believe it what matters is they view it
as an insurrection and that means they
want to pass laws as such which means
the ideological battle has escalated the
point where one side overtly is saying
the other side tried to stage a military
coup and they will not allow them
to continue their conspiracy an article
from the philadelphia inquirer they say
the conspiracy is still happening so
these people are actually in a state of
believing a civil war is underway and
like to the point of subversion but
let's talk about it we also got some
other crazy stories too i mean on a
lighter note elon musk was named person
of the year and on a darker note a cnn
producer was arrested for child
trafficking
so uh yikes joining us to talk about all
of this is the arbiter of internet
morality suraj hashmi how's it going man
high praise coming from mutants
thanks for having me
what do you do what do you want what's
going on oh
i have to explain myself every time wow
give it a good 15 seconds all right
siraj hashmi i'm the creator of the list
also co-host of the habibi power hour
habibi bros me and jay majah kobe the
man who can always be banned by twitter
but always comes back you can follow me
on twitter
me so the list is um the list of people
who should have their phones taken away
right based on bad takes there you go
we got a big list don't we oh yeah we're
doing it we're doing it we're good yeah
we're going to do a live breakdown of
all of these really awful things stupid
people say that oh yeah from the past
week
all right it's gonna be fun thanks for
hanging out man thanks for coming we got
luke it's good to have the habibi and
chief join us today i appreciate you
coming here and uh the shirts that i'm
wearing today is
the grinch who stole normal life and
very coincidentally the grinch looks a
lot like dr fauci now if dr fauci has an
issue with this don't worry we're only
going to take two weeks to slow the
spread of this incredible merchandise
which you can get exclusively on the
best political shirts dot com speed the
spread
what do you mean speed the spread slow
the spread we need two weeks to slow the
spread if dr fauci doesn't like his
depiction here on on this t-shirt and
that's why you know it's just going to
be two weeks tim and and then you know
the shirt's gone and everything's going
going back to normal everything's gonna
be fine so thanks for having me and uh
because you support me i'm here
i gotta say siraj your work with the
list has inspired me i've had many
tweets where i've written them and sat
there and stared at the screen and
they've deleted
many times i've been glad that i did so
thank you for keeping me the task my man
you know the list is all about saving
people from themselves that was the
initial intent behind it and you know if
if i'm if it happens to you ian you know
my job is done glorious i do have to be
honest though um you you jokingly
threatened me with the list i did cause
i said my political positions are as
follows the government sucks comma
mostly and you were like mostly yeah you
know but
which is correct it's all of it yeah
well you know i couldn't i initially
wrote that but i had to add them mostly
because i'm like i'm not an anarchist
i'm just like are you tim yeah i'm not
an anarchist yet are you sure yeah
there's like there's like little little
little there's like bits of government
that i think is a good thing what's
what's what's that right behind you
is that is that the old
is that the knife
is that the sword it's a cutting
and a
muzzle loaded flintlock a flintlock
pistol yes yeah it's not an actual
firearm oh because there's like it's i
guess it's not a legally one no no but
here's i was going to say there's
nothing um i i think i i i have to get
on the list at some point like death by
a thousand cuts
tim this is the issue here if you try to
get on the list you don't get on the
list
what i'm saying is not that any of my
tweets you said you don't put trolls on
the list i don't put trolls on the list
and so but the issue is at a certain
point like i've tweeted so much stupid
stuff like trolling yeah i'd be like all
right just knock it off and smack them
the thing is all right if i didn't know
you
you'd do it then i might consider it
because i don't know you because
sometimes you cannot tell someone you
don't know is trolling when they're
trolling it's like all trolling so tim
whenever you decide you want to get real
serious and it's a bad take don't worry
i'll be right there have you found you
put people on that are trolling before
you realized they were trolling uh yeah
they're i've i've fallen for that trap
several times yeah
and that's why that's why i was like if
they're trolling they can't go on it
because i feel like they should get out
they're they're on their own well yeah
because they're trying to get attention
and i'm giving it to them yeah yeah i'm
not trolling necessarily get attention i
just you know like posting sarcastic
snarky and nonsensical things sometimes
tim do you really need the tension right
now no i don't care
that's that's the thing though i think i
think people need to understand that
about uh when when when you make like if
you made a video where you like lied
about uh um having a twitter beef or
something desperate for attention it
makes you look pathetic you know exactly
and if you just do your thing and mind
your own business we won't talk about
you fine i was trending for like six
weeks straight so weird and i'm like
just stop man like but i get it i get it
we got a show let's carry on with the
show let's do the show okay all right
let's get started we'll ramble on this a
second before we get started head over
to teamcast.com become a member and help
support all of our awesome new shows we
got pop culture crisis a new pop culture
show talking about movies video games
celebrity stuff because we want people
to have a break from the crazy chaos and
get a well-rounded view of everything
that's going on and sometimes there's
just stuff you want to enjoy like
spider-man's coming out
we're going to talk about spider-man
spider-man's awesome but you also get
access to our members only segments for
the tim castro podcast which go up every
day around 11 or so p.m monday through
thursday check that out and membership
is what drives all of this we're not
chasing clicks or traffic we're just
trying to get people who believe in us
to bail up be like hey man we'll sign up
and help you keep doing the work you do
so it's greatly appreciated don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel share this show with your
friends and i will announce for all of
you we do have the ladies version of the
step on snack and find out shirt now
available go to timcast.com click that
store and you can see the step on snack
and find out women's comfort tea we also
added a whole bunch of colors to the
step on snack uh how do i get what is
this changing color that green one's
really nice yeah they're they're cool
colors look at that look at going
through all the colors here we go the
step on snack and find out shirt now is
a bunch of other colors as well there's
like a darker yellowish orange a lot of
people are saying they want different
colors so um this has been our best
selling shirt ever like no joke we've
sold thousands of them in like a month
so thank you so much for all the support
everybody
with that being said let's talk about
the news we got the story from the new
york times we are edging closer to civil
war
and even fox news writes an article
saying liberal uh analyst or whatever
pundit writes that we're closer to a
civil war because fox news can't just be
like here's the argument they have to
make sure you know the guy who wrote
it's a liberal
charles m blow writes supreme court
issued a decision allowing abortion
providers in texas to continue
challenging new laws we know that i'm
not going to get into the nitty-gritty
of him talking about what happened with
that cause i'll give you the simple
version it's widely believed that come
june 2022 the supreme court will
overturn roe v wade now i don't know if
that means it'll happen if it's probable
or not it just means a bunch of
mainstream outlets said conservative
justices were signaling they would
overturn it and a bunch of the
progressive personalities were like it's
over the end is nigh
however what he goes on to say is
something really interesting in this
article he brings up in 1837
calhoun railed in a speech on the senate
floor that slavery had grown up with our
society and institutions and is so
interwoven with them that to destroy it
would be to destroy us as a people he
mentions that calhoun was considered the
father of secession the interesting
thing i see here when talking about the
escalation of conflict uh and and the
cold civil war is what's the catalyst
certainly you have tribalism where
people care more about their cause than
the system and that's what ray dalio the
hedge fund billionaires brought up
saying that's why he believes we face a
very serious chance of civil war but
what is the spark the shot heard around
the world that's going to be it's going
to light the match
i think it could be abortion i think
what might happen is
june 2022 supreme court overturns roe v
roe v wade maybe i don't know but let's
just say maybe it happens
then comes the midterms republicans say
now is our chance to pass federal
legislation banning abortion federally
and republicans rally around the idea of
course democrats will rally too but
let's say in the circumstance
republicans actually end up winning
they then try to pass the legislation
but joe biden vetoes it and they don't
have the the amount they don't have the
the power in congress to override the
veto so now comes 2024 donald trump is
campaigning and says the first thing
he'll do when he's elected is sign the
bill federally banning abortion which
brings us back to the 2020 election when
john podesta as it was reported by the
boston globe said if donald trump wins
he would encourage the west coast to
secede from the union now i don't know
if they'll overturn roe v wade it kind
of sounds crazy seems crazy they would
i don't know if there's going to be a
red wave or a red tsunami
it seems like based on indicators that
might be the case and i don't know if
trump will actually win but these pieces
are certainly in play and the new york
times is actually entertaining the idea
and many other mainstream publications
have as well
so i certainly think it's fair to say
the conversation is here it's in the new
york times what charles blow writes he
says this war won't be only about
subjugation of black people but also
about the subjugation subjugation of all
who challenge the white racist
patriarchy it will seek to push back
against all the others black people
immigrants muslims jews lgbtq people and
yes women particularly liberal ones and
thus he goes back to bringing up
abortion
now i don't know about all that that
sounds pretty darn crazy to me because i
certainly don't think the right in
sphere of influence faction has is white
supremacists or believes whatever the
hell they're this guy's saying but they
believe it and that means they're
willing to fight for it and they believe
this escalated to that point
so i don't know what you guys think i've
been harping on this for for a long time
positive negative you think something
bad's gonna happen i i mean
you mentioned the cold civil war
i think we're there
but more so on information
we're dealing with two different
americas right now you have a right and
left
and both sides don't seem to want to
basically come to terms with what the
other side is saying
and
it's become more divisive than ever
it's supplanted religion as probably the
one single great divider and it's i mean
it's obviously not healthy
and unfortunately uh
you know you see a lot of uh
i mean just last week i think axios was
reporting that a lot of these
conservative or right-wing uh platforms
are starting up um and it's creating an
echo chamber which is
which is yeah which is funny considering
that their entire their entire argument
was oh you don't like it go build your
own thing and then they did now they're
complaining about it or that their whole
infrastructure is an echo chamber and so
when some people are like i don't want
to be in an echo chamber they're like
you're making an echo chamber yeah yeah
the corporate media is an echo chamber
absolutely and i think this article is
absolutely hyperbolic i mean to claim
that white supremacists are going to go
are going to be targeting minorities and
the lgbt community and liberal women
specifically sounds a lot more like
propaganda than any kind of prophecy i
mean i i do see the potential of of this
larger divide and conquer agenda but i
see this kind of article as a ploy to
push that divide even further with a lot
of the fear-mongering scare tactics
implemented in this article that again
are just absolutely baseless
when you see see it in its face value
now again we are becoming more
politically uh partisan we are becoming
very uh divided uh we are living in
bigger and bigger echo chambers but i do
believe financially that it's going to
be a bigger ramification of utter chaos
happening in the financial sector that's
going to create little groups and these
groups will be fighting each other and i
think that's going to be the more
likelihood of a potential civil war
potentially later down the line i just
wanted to add one thing that really you
know that strikes me as
the corporate media and and sort of like
the elite are dividing us by all these
different identities it's identity
politics
what this really would boil down to if
they weren't dividing us into all these
different groups as it would be a class
a classist type of
divide it would be
the the ruling elite would
basically
be the subject of everybody's
frustration and there would be a good
chance that
the people the powers that be would no
longer be there if people would stop
fighting with each other
but the interesting thing is it's not
the the when they talk about you know
white supremacist and all that stuff
that's one of the lies they use to keep
to make the divide happen but that's not
it's clearly a lie what what the actual
battle is in my opinion is reality
versus the matrix
there are people who live in a
fictitious reality based upon mainstream
narratives that are not true and there
are people who are discerning they
challenge narratives and they try to
figure out what's what is true and that
means sometimes cnn writes an article
that's true and sometimes they don't you
got to be able to figure out what makes
sense and what doesn't for a lot of
people
they uh a good example is steve bannon
you know we've had on the show several
times the dude is clearly not a white
supremacist but if you go to these
leftists they will genuinely tell you
not in these stupid fake semantics they
will genuinely tell you they believe
steve bannon thinks he's genetically
superior to black people which is just
not true
i don't think he even talks about
anything related to that stuff or race
at all he comes here and he's like the
rich people are ripping
ripping you off we've got to raise the
taxes he's a populist right but but if
so so when you have someone like steve
bannon who could make an argument
that a populist leftist would completely
agree with but they won't talk to him
because they're scared of the
establishment
that's the driving wedge there are some
people who know absolutely that you know
alex jones is you know he can be out
there sometimes but he's popular steve
bannon he's a populist but they won't
come and sit down and talk to him you
know why
we've actually reached out to many of
the populist leftists like hey would you
want to come and join this show like
talk to these individuals and they're
like no no i don't think so sorry i'm
not interested
i will tell you this my belief is that
and it's just speculation for the most
part what do you think would happen if a
progressive leftist sat down with steve
bannon for two hours just kept saying i
agree you're right i agree you're right
that's correct yes that's true yes i
agree with you i mean they get canceled
yeah absolutely they get ripped shreds
actually it's kind of funny because uh
shoe on head you're familiar with shoes
oh yeah of course she's oftentimes
branded as
now basically being like a
you know right-wing populist because she
doesn't treat
people on the right like they're evil
even though she is very much progressive
and i've we've had her on the show we've
had her on the bb power hour and she was
a great guest and uh
that the thing is
the biggest threat to the establishment
is people using their brains they just
hope people will never think for
themselves and when they start to
then they have a problem so right the
idea is to just constantly dumb people
down and use simple terms and create
narratives that aren't true and if
anybody strays from that line they're
demonized for it yeah and if anybody
criticizes the intelligence agencies
they're definitely attacked for just
like
also talks about the intelligence
agencies which is which is very rare but
the few people that do actually hit the
the nail right on the head for a lot of
the issues that are being caused a lot
of the central controllers a lot of the
people who create the algorithms that
helped build a lot of the big tech
platforms i think that's one of the key
issues what's that what's that saying
luke what's the the highest prize in
journalism it's not the pulitzer it's a
it's a cia assassination bulletin
but this is but but this is the kind of
web that the media spins and i think
they do this deliberately and there is
cohesion and there is collaboration that
does happen with the intelligence
agencies and the corporate media that
has been documented throughout the years
especially with
a german prize-winning journalist ufc
who was talking about how essentially
the cia was writing press releases for
him that he put his name under in some
of the biggest publications in the world
but with this new york times article
it's pretty much telling their few
limousine liberal viewers and readers
like hey these white guys are going to
kill you because if you're different and
then of course there's also bad parties
on the other side saying hey these guys
are going to hurt you because you're
different and in reality these people
have a lot more in common than they have
then it divides them but these divisions
i believe are even uh not just hyperbol
hyperbolically overplayed but they're
also created when they're not even there
and and there's like literally people
created genders and religious views and
points of views that never existed only
way to to kind of sow division amongst
everyone else and i think that's that's
absolutely needs to be called out yeah
like race uh what is it race wars
political strife is great for ratings
civil war great for ratings
gangbusters great for ratings fear fear
fear great for ratings
watch out for it see it when it arrives
and and navigate it all right well this
is this is the big challenge even we
face right i mean the new york times
writes about this they say the big you
know specter of the right wing is going
to oppress all the women and minorities
and it's clearly insane right there i
think i think like the last legitimate
count of white supremacists in the us
was like 11 000 people like legit you
know like people going to meetings or or
trying to
and then
even the woke left i think the a couple
of years ago was
the um progressives were viewed around
eight percent of the country one of the
challenges though is when you have an
establishment that tells people a civil
war is coming and this is where the
narrative started didn't start with me
it started with i think it was the
atlantic they said we surveyed a bunch
of people a bunch of security experts
who said they believe there's a 30 to 90
chance of a civil war in the next 10
years then you get the princeton
professor the the hill publishes an
article about it they're all
entertaining this
when you have that narrative coming up
in the establishment and then you get a
bunch of
mindless
you know uninitiated you know political
individuals who don't know anything
about what's going on but believe it
you're effectively dealing with
i guess a self-fulfilling prophecy yeah
because if you if you think a civil war
is coming then you're going to get right
like you know in a fantasy realm you're
afraid you're going to be attacked you
get your weapon you get stand guard and
when you see someone coming you assume
that's the person that's going to attack
you
so like so right right but here's here's
what i want to make sure i'm clarifying
i'm trying to be defensive i'm trying to
be self-critical a little bit i don't
want to make you think that i was not
what i'm saying is
we see that and then we literally do a
video where we're like mainstream media
article says civil war is coming we talk
about why it you know they're fanning
the flames of can possibly create it but
then us talking about it also creates
that conversation so a lot of people are
like as much as tim brings this up he
sure must want it and i'm like i'm
criticizing the concept and what the
mainstream media has been telling
everybody but when you have these
articles coming out saying trump was
staging a military coup there was an
insurrection
and that's years after they've already
been saying it's coming and the right's
going to do this to you and that to you
it is like it's escalating like we're
getting to that point like what so what
do we do do we just ignore it and not
talk about it while the zombie hordes
you know keep expanding
if you remember even before the first
iraq war there was a ton of buildup
there was there was a ton of propaganda
there was a ton of corporate media
saying we need to bomb iraq and they
laid the groundwork they pretty much
made people okay with this larger idea
that the united states is going to go to
war with iraq which is absolutely a
delusional crazy idea but they had to
sell that idea for a very long time and
they primed it by talking about it for
months and years beforehand so this
could be a similar situation but we also
saw something similar with syria it
never led to a full-out war in syria
even though there was a big buildup
there was a big military corporate
military-industrial complex campaign to
start a war there it never really
happened because of the backlash against
it but with the iraq there was there was
still backlash and they still did it
anyway so it's a very complex kind of
media landscape i think i finally
understand why brian williams left msnbc
so he could fight on the front lines
keith olbermann keith olbermann's
already fighting he said he already lost
his mind in the process of doing so but
uh he gave it all we could say that
check out the story we got from the
philadelphia inquirer
this is look
this this story is a level of deranged
nothing i'm gonna read the quote this is
the title nothing is more important than
team trump's january powerpoint urging a
full-blown coup
the scariest part about trump's coup
plot including a banana republic style
national emergency is that the
conspiracy is still happening
is it
the philadelphia enquirer a mainstream
publication is outright telling the
people of this country namely
philadelphia but also the country that
there is a current ongoing donald trump
conspiracy to take over the country
now what do you think that's going to do
to someone's mind you got the new york
times saying the white supremacists are
coming for you they're going to they're
going to target especially liberal women
it's almost like they're trying
themselves to target liberal women with
fear to make them lose their minds
and i'll tell you something interesting
too
women in suburban women in virginia
voted for yunkan they voted republican
clearly suburban women do not like
donald trump
now you have the philadelphia inquirer
saying the conspiracy with trump is
still happening it's a full-blown
military coup and here's the proof
these people live in
a very twisted version it's like a
bizarro world cliques
if they do won't that make them so
here's my theory
there are people who are finally over
covered they're done with the fear
factor of it
so what do you get in place of it
civil war
coup
trump takeover of the country i i
disagree man i i i partly agree i think
there's a craving for like like the
media is like what can we pump up
but back in 2018 i said if what we're
seeing with the street fighting across
the country popping up all over the
place continues then i think we are
heading towards some kind of civil war i
don't know exactly how that will
manifest but people make the mistake of
believing it's going to be a mason-dixon
line and the state's going like that it
could be something crazy i don't know
then in 2019 we saw you know more signs
of it it was back in 2018 these articles
popped up and then i started talking to
people and they were like you're crazy
that's the stupidest thing i've ever
heard
i would have conservatives in dc tell me
that and i'm like what makes you think
it couldn't happen like why do you have
that optimism bias it'll never happen
here and the response i got was
what's happening with antifa and proud
boys and right-wing groups and stuff is
is is a bunch of low-level you know
board losers fighting in the streets and
it will never reach the point of the
seat of government it will never be in
the federal government and the security
state will shut it down
now
we have
you know political like fighting between
you know the progressive wing and the
populist right wing in congress threats
of arrest against some of them nancy
pelosi saying some of them should be
investigated how many of them do you
think are feds
which ones all of them
yeah maybe a lot of
our congressmen you think they went
undercover and ran for office no i mean
like antifa probably boys i mean just
like how many of them a ton of them but
so so so which is interesting but the
point was brought to me was the federal
government will never allow it to happen
and i'm like what happens when this
conflict reaches the federal government
if the millennial generation and younger
is divided to an extreme degree
and they are taking these seats of power
in 10 20 years millennials are going to
be the majority of like 80 90 of
congress
and that culture war is going to be in
congress it's going to be in the
president it's going to be in the senate
god
yeah right the congress will be
insufferable then i mean it's not
insufferable now yeah let's get buzzfeed
less the clothes this is what this
congressman did
yeah but like
if if if these people who genuinely
believe this stuff are in that seat of
power then it the culture war does reach
the government and then
and then what happens they get stripped
of their power no way who well no i
think angry mob i think the culture will
already reach the federal government
through trump because he
he was very much
leading the charge
in that cultural war i mean as soon as
you had you know colin kaepernick kneel
uh during the national anthem
trump took that as an issue and boom as
soon as he said something about it in i
think what 2018
then all of a sudden
it never left you're right
the culture war reaching the federal
government was the 2015 election cycle
before that we had you know what mitt
romney barack obama in 2012 and it was
very stodgy boring establishment
politics yeah but in 2015 the culture
war reached a point where people were
voting on this and it was the
establishment versus the
i guess the cultural independence the
trump people the the populists
well so
it used to be politics was a bunch of
stodgy boring you know the lesser of two
evils but then trump comes along and he
is like you know a bull gonna storm
through and smash everything up all of a
sudden now the seat of the federal
government was a culture war issue yeah
now it's 2020 we're entering 2022 how
crazy is that we got to call trump the
rhino in the china shop because he's a
rhino
and this is like he's a liberal guy
random the republican he's a rhino
republican i mean he's not really a
republican exactly no he's not true call
him the bull i'm gonna call him trump is
trump is trump i mean
hey so here's here's what i will also
happen to be a republican yeah this time
are next to his name we had um i think
was ryan long was here and i love ryan
he's great we yeah he's hate him though
they don't like him really he he got he
got me he uh he threw a hard question at
me right when we started the show
he was like he's like so tim the last
time i was here he said a civil war is
coming you got me all freaked out and
then what's going on and then i went
on january 6th about 800 people stormed
into the capitol trying to shut down
so i had all these people telling me
that nothing was going to happen we
weren't getting close to a civil war now
these establishment liberal types when
they say to me i just do the same thing
they go where's civil war tim
on january 6 800 trump supporters
stormed into the like i don't know is
that enough for you i don't think it was
as bad as they say it was yeah for them
is it and they're like oh yeah and now
they're saying the coup is still
happening well that's the thing yeah
that's the thing i mean it's it's almost
like they just want to be right every
single time or they don't want to give
you a credit
i mean
what i think maybe the reality is
like
how how how does this train stop
because there's like do the trump
supporters who are sitting sitting in
the prisons right now in the solitary
confinement do they get released and
then walk up to abiding supporter and
just cry and then hug and say it's
america damn it and like we don't want
this anymore or do they say i was
tortured
by his estate by his administration by
his doj
and then does this result in people
saying the system is corrupt
and the left is saying but they're
insurrectionists who should be honestly
i think a lot of it is even happening
now over you know a lot of these coveted
restrictions vaccine mandates mass
mandates there are odds strange there's
some strange bev fellows kind of working
together
on the left and right who oppose a lot
of these restrictions and
honestly that might not be enough to
heal the country but it's brought some
people together
i mean we've seen black lives matter
marching with right wing groups in new
york yeah saying opposing the vast
mandates but is it possible that that
actually is just part of
further decay of the system i mean you
don't have you don't have friends or
enemies you have common interests in
politics that's just how it's always
been and so
i mean they have common goals
and once they
say
accomplish that goal then they'll go
back to fighting each other so maybe
maybe that's the normal we're going back
to
i think
if if we look if i try to look at this
optimistically like it's not going to
get that bad because something will
divert attention and the factions will
shift again before it gets too bad it
kind of just feels like you know the
swing is getting too far left too far
right and then eventually the swing is
too much and the tower topples over you
know what i mean yeah like right now
it's shaking we got a bad earthquake but
not enough to knock the the structure of
the united states down
but if it keeps happening and the the
swings get more and more extreme then
eventually the whole thing's going to
just implode on itself well the
conditions that are creating the
hyperbolic you know political moments
they're only increasing in their power
and influence if you look at big tech
it's only becoming more influential in
our lives if you look at the corporate
media it's being force-fed on us even
more those are the two biggest
contributors those are the gasoline on
the fire of this quiet cold civil war
that some people say is happening right
now and those two institutions are not
going away they're only becoming more
powerful and i think it's in their
interest to have people fighting each
other because they also represent a lot
of very powerful people and those
powerful people don't want them looking
up and recognizing that the true source
of their problems is the multinational
corporations is the billionaire class
that is able to buy off government buy
off big tech social media and it is them
fighting each other based off trivial
differences based off their dna their
preferences and if they can have people
fighting with the pitchforks against the
torches when they have those two people
going against each other no one's
focusing on any of the legitimate
problems that is directly affecting
their lives and and and how they live in
this existence but that just means that
eventually the system crumbles and the
elites escape with as much resources
exactly i mean the elites already have
have a huge have accumulated so much
resources so much money but but the
elites never historically understand
when enough is enough uh if if you look
at every time a country was was was
robbed of its wealth if you look at all
the hyperinflation cases whether it's
weimar germany whether it's uh argentina
whether it's zimbabwe whether it's
venezuela it's always people saying this
is for me i don't care about anyone else
the rats are you know leaving here let's
plunder what we can that has always
happened through recorded human history
especially when you have a government
willing to increase the debt ceiling
increase the money printing increase
government programs that stand in the
way of free economic flow of income and
money and capital so this is only going
to get worse because of the financial
ramifications which i think are critical
here because that's going to be the
other kind of match you have the fuel by
by the the
corporate media the fuel by by the the
social media but the match i think is
going to be the financial larger
ramifications luke i believe you are
correct we have a story from cnn
food is more expensive than it has been
in decades cnn you know broken clock
right twice a day bad news for american
consumers it's getting more expensive to
dine out and getting more expensive to
eat at home restaurant prices spiked 5.8
percent of the last 12 months ending in
november without seasonal adjustments
the bureau of labor statistics said
friday that's the largest 12-month
increase since the year ended january
1982. and unfortunately for those hoping
to curb spending by turning to home
cooking grocery store prices are also at
record highs they jumped six point four
percent the largest 12 month increa
increase since 2008 beef had the most
dramatic increase with a 20.9 spike in
prices
so let me ask you guys something what do
you think
is was was the catalyst for the arab
spring
do you know this one worker who was
having a hard time making ends meet and
because of the government finding him
and regulating him he ended up
committing suicide and his story went
viral
i'm uh that's that's the essence of what
i understood it to be from some of the
stories that i heard but i think tim you
would you'd know a little bit more about
this yes i got the name wrong earlier it
was muhammad wazizi that's about i'm
saying that wrong was these members was
easy it was easy yeah he uh he immolated
himself
um he was trying to i believe what
happened was he was trying to sell fruit
he was born in uh 29th of march 1984 and
he kept getting the government kept
interfering with his ability to to make
a living and eventually he couldn't so
he just went in front of a government
building and dumped fuel on himself and
immolated himself and this sparked the
the protests in tunisia which started
swooping across these other uh you know
other parts of the the arab world
resulting as many believe in the arab
spring
there were some experts who reviewed why
it reached the point where people were
willing to overthrow their government
and there were a few key factors one of
which was
inflation
yes unemployment the price of food yeah
so people could no longer afford to eat
what happens when someone can't eat oh
they get crazy do people just say well i
got no food so i guess i'll just lay
down here and die well i mean they do
have ramadan
fasting is good for you it's okay i'm
muslim i can make these jokes
yeah there there's something different
about you know choosing because when you
choose to fast you're in control and you
know you're in control right and you
know the food's waiting for you yeah you
don't know exactly when oh totally
together you can prep your body too like
the day before you load up on whatever
you need for the week yeah overnight or
whatever and you fast from sunrise to
sunset and no water
but people drive fast
people often say especially the super
chats here they tell me that you know
one of the things i'm you know they oh i
would love to stand up and and talk
about these issues but i have to make
sure my kids have food so the wager
right now among many of these people is
that by complying with the tyranny and
what what they're doing with mass
spending and you know everything's
burning the system down their kids will
eat for a longer period of time than if
they were to stand up and speak up
because then their kids they could get
fired and they can't get food for their
kids
i think what hap i think what drives
people towards you know
revolt and conflict in crisis in a
country civil war even they can't feed
their kids yeah and it's it's partly
about themselves i mean what is the
first thing i mean the first things is
like food on the table
roof over your head
and what a place to sleep
or something like that i think it's
what's that order i think it's a safety
i think it's i think it's food shelter
and safety yeah security like um the
things that cause massive stress right
if you can't eat your pants obviously
the first one is safety
i'm just saying in terms of like food
people no no
yeah maybe we're complaining things but
i meant like the the usually the goal
like when you're trying to provide for
your family the first thing you always
go for is food on the table
you can't provide food on the table yeah
then there you got nothing yeah you're
screwed but at least you have a table
but then if you have no table now you're
cold you're scared and then there's
there's violence or the police are
threatening you you have no safety
people just finally snap
and and there's stories coming out of
germany where people killed themselves
because of the lockdowns and the vax
mandates their stories of a person
lighting themselves on fire killing
themselves in australia because of the
lockdowns because of the vaccine
mandates so these stories are already
happening and i think they're only going
to be exacerbated especially here in the
united states where americans are
already dealing with some of the highest
inflation in over 40 years joe biden
just gave an extra 20 billion dollars
for the defense budget and there's a
clear there's a clear sign that when the
government gets involved almost every
step of the way they are making the
situation that much worse and i think
financially socially when people are
going to see the larger effects of this
as they are already seeing the largest
transfer of wealth in recorded human
history it's going to hit them hard it's
already hitting them hard but this is
only the beginning of this major wave
coming our way that was produced by
government and i don't think there's any
escaping it i don't think there's any uh
life raft we might be able to if we
develop fusion power and like central
decentralized power sources and then the
powerful people just keep the technology
for themselves and don't release it to
the general public and then hide it from
everyone else just like free energy that
would be a problem then we would still
see a crash of the system i think the
system could
find some sort of resilience if we can
decentralize our power sources
other than energy yeah but you know
what's what what happened when biden got
into uh office the administration
basically stripped the us of energy
independence
not that i'm saying petroleum energy
independence is necessarily what your
voice is heavy that's the problem with
it but it is extremely energy dense so
america was we were in that exporter of
oil that's crazy right we were and now
biden's like nordstrom 2. go ahead
russia you get your own pipeline and now
they're like well it's leverage now well
have we ever entertained the possibility
that by then might be a kremlin agent
actually no no and that one actually
makes the most sense which is funny
you know hey not that i think it makes
sense
he's pressuring ukraine to cede
territory to the russians i mean come on
if trump did that everybody would be
losing their minds that'd be front page
news on everything nobody's talking
about it nope
it's not even leading this show not to
obviously we we didn't talk about it we
left this weekend evan do you think he
did it so just to be like
was his intention like hey ukraine don't
get involved in a hot war with russia
just give yeah that was his intention
yeah basically
do you believe that's what it seems like
his intention would be on the surface
but
what if what if putin actually has
compromat on biden and he's had it the
whole time
you know yeah he's tape is real but it's
biden not trump
okay
it's probably hunter
no no no no no the p tape for those
aren't familiar was it donald trump at a
hotel yeah in russia what did he do he
peed on the bed no no no he paid women
to
uh release their liquids onto him
i told my mom this was going to be a
halal shot
hey i'm using family friendly language
here yeah here see that was a
manipulation they the establishment
wanted to run joe biden they knew they
were going to be up against these rumors
so they took control of the narrative
the real story is there is a p-tape it
is not of trump it is of biden and it's
not it's not women of the night it's
that bite it is old and incontinent and
was sitting in the bed he went
and someone got it on camera
hey look he who is without peeing their
bed casts the first stuff
i think every every person at some point
in their life
just give over to it you ever have a
dream where you're peeing in your dream
and then you wake up and you're actually
peeing no i mean maybe once i say that
out loud
it happened i think maybe when i was a
little kid yeah yeah that's what i meant
when i was a kid
not last week
last week
i don't know man um how do we pivot from
that
ukraine came up and then you know joe
biden's seeding territory to the
russians that that was like food prices
yeah we were on food yeah let's talk
food
well yeah man um i thought inflation was
a good thing
cnn didn't didn't you have more money
didn't cnn write that inflation was a
good thing yeah yeah i think the
intercept also i think you have like
that that pissed me off yeah bloomberg
is good yeah there was a twitter thread
that i highlighted today it was actually
i saw uh um
i saw somebody retweet this thread where
a guy basically says
right you know average people middle
class people poor people don't
understand what it like what it's like
being rich
and they assume
they assume a lot of things about rich
people now the funny thing is i
certainly think the guy was like i would
i wish poor people could spend a day in
the shoes of a rich person so they could
understand and i'm like dude being rich
is great being poor sucks
however you ever watch trading places
but but
it it is partly true what he was
basically saying is that the world is
made for average people not for rich
people
and
regular people have this assumption that
rich people can do things they can't do
they can just like get whatever they
want so this is what really bothered me
about um
well this is a good context in relation
to the intercept article the intercept
article talking about inflation when
people can't afford to eat was like the
rich people hate inflation and i'm just
like no they don't they can exploit it
very easily without question they can
exploit inflation you buy a piece of
property the property spikes when
inflation hits and then you sell it
later and you kept your money didn't
lose any buying power a poor person they
they can't buy property so they get a
paycheck and that's just worth 10 less
you know you know when they put in their
savings
but it is true and it's important to
point out
people in this country don't understand
how finance laws work they don't
understand how money works so they get
they get screwed over by the likes of
the intercept they get screwed over by
the likes of cnn but the weirdest thing
is what if how does someone read cnn and
see inflation as good as an op-ed and
then read food is more expensive than it
has been and it's hurting people and
just be like i'm gonna keep reading this
publication
like they told me two different things
but you know whatever
you know some people just want to be
they want to have their biases confirmed
and
these news publications the corporate
media will just continue to feed them
that dribble even if it works against
their own self-interest
and at the point it's like it's like uh
you know the glutton that you keep
feeding it and they're killing
themselves i was just gonna say drugs
there's probably a lot of drug addicts
out there who don't know and have any
common sense or sense of reality and
they're just blindly gazed at cnn with
their mouth drooling open and then you
know just just losing iq points as they
they engage more in that dribble and
absolute nonsense because there's no way
to see the real life ramifications of
inflation and then to think that it's
okay inflation of course first affects
the most poorest people since of course
common goods go up that are mostly
readily available for everyone um and
then of course later down online it
impacts a lot of other people bloomberg
had another insane article talking about
how people should spend their paychecks
right away while of course borrowing
money as much as they can at the same
time to battle inflation it's it's
absolutely ridiculous policy to have jim
cramer up on national television saying
that we have the strongest economy than
we ever have ever and then and then his
former substance abuse having self
being on the same news organization that
is reporting record high inflation
there's there's no way you could have
both and there's obviously a huge
disconnect between reality and what the
corporate media is telling you i think
they're meant to confuse you but i think
there's also a small population that
wants to be kind of consoled by these
corporate heads and told everything's
going to be okay this inflation's great
for you it's all going to work out fine
just give up all your powers to the
bankers just give up all your
sovereignty give up all your liberty and
freedom it's all going to be one thing i
want to pull this article real quick
sure yeah just because luke referenced
it yeah bloomberg is mercilessly mocked
after advising americans to spend their
paycheck immediately and borrow lots of
money to tackle inflation in similar
advice given to economic basket case
argentina uh we're imploding yeah
they're like negotiate a pay raise or
two to get a house
how how can the average person afford a
house it's absolutely crazy uh
especially on modern wages especially
with their wages being devalued compared
to of course inflation people's savings
their whole life savings is are
absolutely being ruined right now
it's the value of the dollars being
devalued while of course the richest
people take whatever they could get the
billionaires are more richer than they
ever have been and they're only going to
become more richer from here one thing
that you know then the last time i was
on your show was my last day at the
washington examiner i've been
independent since that's nine months ago
and what i've learned in those nine
months is that
the corporate media
and a lot of these elites
i feel like their only purpose
is to gaslight us they're just they
solely exist
just to drive us all insane
and when you have stories like this it
sort of reaffirms that idea
that
they're telling you that the
sky is is brown when it's clearly blue
it's just
i don't know why and then you go on
twitter and you're like here's a picture
of the sky and then you get these
establishment new york times pundits
being telling you know far right and and
also they use it as a power play because
then they could say that person is crazy
that's why you need to give us more
power and vote for us because if you
give these people power
then you're screwed yeah and more people
are going insane if you look at mental
health there has been an absolute
downward trajectory ever since the onset
of social media that is causing
self-harm that is causing suicide that
is causing depression and it's causing a
huge spike in prescriptions
by of course big pharma that's giving
off
ssris and a lot of other drugs to battle
a lot of people's negative uh health
mental health specifically that they're
uh that's only becoming more of a bigger
problem more by the day let me let me
read a little bit from this article it
says the piece takes advice from
argentinians on how they deal with
soaring inflation in a country ravaged
by 50
price rises in a typical year an extreme
increase in the cost of living that's
officially called hyperinflation among
the handy tips it advises americans to
negotiate a pay raise or two and to buy
homes and cars the article has been
savaged by commentators who claim it's
hopelessly out of touch with americans
facing the highest rate of inflation in
40 years
ian miles chong wrote america is turning
into the weimar republic with financial
magazines advising people to spend their
paychecks as soon as they get them as
soon as they get paid hyperinflation is
coming
now look at this
i don't know if uh if if you can call it
hyperinflation because that's sort of
like a you know nebulous term inflation
is the word hyperinflation just means
you know a lot of it
we're dealing with a major spike in
inflation they're spending more and more
money they're printing more and more
money the m1 money stock skyrocketed
when they converted savings into
effectively the checking accounts but
it's still skyrocketing faster than
we've ever seen
i think hyperinflation is coming i think
unless there's some kind of major in
like serious conflict crisis
intervention or lockdown or something
we are going to see like hyperinflation
and that being said any kind of
intervention could only exacerbate it so
i just i don't understand how you avoid
this mate on the screen right now i have
an image showing this major spike
in the past year and it and it tracks
alongside perfectly what we see with the
m1 money supply you see one major spike
straight up and then it curves a little
bit and then goes up at a similar rate
it's almost nice too almost at six point
nine percent oh yeah it's been pretty
good
if it was six point nine we'd be chill
about yeah yeah six point eight i'd be
okay with it but six point eight oh
we had max we had max kaiser on the show
what did he say fifteen percent yeah he
says that the real numbers are a lot
bigger than of course the official
numbers that are absolutely
underinflated it's kind of like kind of
like unemployment i've been i've been
saying this to for a while like
especially here running the business i
was like whatever we need for the
business let's not wait let's get it now
and the problem is
our attitude is based on witnessing in
real time the the ridiculousness of
inflation and the mass money spending so
you know here we're like what's our
budget we need new cameras for the new
show we need new studio equipment let's
not wait let's buy it now and then build
instead of you know building out the
hardware like building out the the set
design and then getting the equipment to
fit it no no just buy it now we'll
figure it out later because if we wait a
month or two the price is going to go up
20 to 30 50 bucks who knows could even
go up way more than that so let's spend
it now that's a problem
because if people have that mentality
and they start buying like crazy that
also sparks more inflation and makes the
spiral happen faster
downward spiral uh maybe it strikes me
as like um the horse problem early 1900s
i think you've mentioned this a few
times where so much horse manure in the
streets that they're like at this rate
the cities are going to be overridden
with horse manure what are we going to
do there's no solution in sight then all
of a sudden the car was invented the
entire problem was eradicated i think
yeah it seems like it's a similar
situation whether or not we do
create the the automobile of the economy
that we need today to solve this i don't
know but it seems like that kind of
problem well it almost seems like
financial collapse is the goal i mean
that's i mean if you think you mentioned
how how the elites obviously becoming
more becoming richer
you also have to factor in the
international
interests that say like the chinese
communist party has in basically buying
up parts of the u.s
more and more financial collapse only
benefits them yep and they want they're
buying land like crazy exactly and if
they can buy more of our debt they'll do
it dude it cannot be understated how how
valuable collapsing an economy is to the
rich people you make
so much money when you collapse an
economy and you're rich
yeah everyone's selling their homes so
they could afford food everyone's
renting instead of owning so that's one
aspect of it is it time to ask if biden
is an agent of china oh yeah wow china
and russia let me show you let me let me
show this tweet so president biden
tweeted the united states pays its debts
when they are due that's why today i
signed a bill to fast-track the process
to raise our debt limit to which i
responded
i remember when my parents had to use
credit cards to pay bills too yeah it's
not good good one that's not good but
it's a it's a it's a serious it's a
serious point
we were never in a good position when it
was like the electric bills do what do
we do it's like a credit card put it on
the credit card
yeah it's like well then you're just
digging yourself into a deep hole that's
literally what the united states has
been doing for a very long time and he's
proud of it and he's like look how good
i am look how great i am i'm signing a
bill that's going to indebt this country
where you can't get out of financially
your children are going to have to pay
for this reckless spending that he's
trying to as he's still trying to pass
the build back better bill and and
fundamental
institutional changes that of course
will just print more money throw more
money into their climate and equity
efforts and all this other ridiculous
nonsense that they're trying to push
forward which will push for more
regulations
more taxes more control of government in
your in your life which i just got to
say the cgi on that video is incredible
you can't even see the strings of the
people
it does look like a green screen a
little bit
is that from the real white oval office
or the set
that's the that looks like the real one
yeah it's gotta be a problem yeah
there's a there's like across the street
they have a sound stage
and it's got like tv screens on the
windows it's not real
it's been a weird past couple of years i
gotta say weird gear yeah maybe maybe
the large hadron collider you know
caused the black hole to swallow the
earth
you know like don lemon said yeah now
we're just in this like weird twisted
reality
where our thoughts are altering where
thoughts become rally reality too much
trump is the president or was it it's
possible that our thoughts are becoming
reality much faster than they used to i
don't know if there's something to we're
just in that we're just in an episode of
black mirror guys yeah
yeah that's all it is like you know we
live in a simulation we take our lives
too seriously but right now there's some
dude watching he's just eating popcorn
he's like dark school show that's it
it's that south park episode of of earth
you know it could be everything seems
you know what's funny is like people
talk about miracles and stuff and i
remember when i was little talking
people about religion they're like when
you're older you see the signs and i was
like well i don't know about that now
i'm older and i'm like there's no way
this is real life
can't be like like joe biden as
president this is crazy
everything that's happening is just
ridiculous and stupid like everybody
knows what's going on with epstein but
like nothing happens there's like a show
trial and everyone just carries along
like everyone i think everyone just kind
of pretends that that the world isn't a
giant fireball because it's the only way
to survive to just be like i'm gonna
keep focused eat my breakfast and go
home and not worry about the laugh to
keep from crying you can only keep your
head in the sand so long until that fire
gets on your family-friendly show on
your uh buttocks and
lights of fire underneath your your
buttocks so i think it's only a matter
of time until people are affected by it
people are already affected by it their
lives were interrupted they were told to
stay home for two weeks and ended up
being bamboozled for over two years with
this absolute draconian totalitarian
nonsense where now artificial
intelligence facial recognition
technology is being used to track trace
and database almost every single move
they make like recently implemented in
south korea like implemented and all the
other nations that were formerly
democratic that are becoming more
despotic by the day it's crazy what's
happening out there and that's why i
think we also need to acknowledge that
there's a lot of protest against it
there's been so many movements there's
been so many demonstrations there have
been so many gatherings from all over
the world from peru to georgia to the
czech republic spain argentina austria
germany france we have seen a huge huge
number of people come together and say
enough is enough i'm sick of this and
for um you know very surprisingly well
not for me but for people the normies
out there the corporate media is not
talking about it at all not even
mentioning any of these mass movements
that are coming together unorganized
what are they doing they're they're
coordinating with the by the
administration behind closed doors to
spin how bad the economy is doing and
it's working like to a certain degree a
bunch of articles popped up right after
that where they were like the economy is
actually good five cents less for gas
this is awesome this is great lemon was
singing
literally pennies i want i wanted to get
into a dark story we'll try to keep
family friendly but i wanna i wanna open
up this uh this very disturbing segment
by um just letting you suraj know did
you know that luke's been to epstein
island
and what
that's the right response that's a good
response what capacity this always
happens all the time it's so frustrating
so who was the first person who like
reacted negatively right the point was
that after the rain everything was
cleared luke got in a speed boat and was
like filming you know island and stuff
but when you tell people luke's been to
epstein island they immediately go like
oh when
well allegedly after he he pre or post
he uh he died
and
you know when there was that video
footage from that drone coming out
allegedly showing someone that looked
exactly like epstein on epstein island
after he allegedly killed himself that's
when we decided to take the speed boats
jump on the island and kind of film and
see whatever we could get from uh that
particular
nasty horrible location where atrocities
were committed i like that pre or post
yeah we got it okay so so
i like to do you know we'll get a little
humor in there and make everybody laugh
on a dark subject because this story is
going to screw you up
from fox news
cnn producer accused of child
crimes
once decried growing news stories of
child abuse cases and old tweets new day
producer john griffin faces up to life
in prison according to this report
i'm trying to keep it family friendly
for you guys who might be having kids
nearby because this is dark stuff he
worked shoulder to shoulder with chris
cuomo
he paid a woman three thousand dollars
to bring her nine-year-old daughter to
his home
where he committed a very serious
atrocity against that child and that's
what he's accused of and i do think it's
fair to say even in the most heinous of
crimes crimes we must recognize and it's
until until proven guilty but these are
very
disturbing accusations against somebody
working high level at cnn we also have
had a bunch of other stories too that i
want to briefly mention you know the cia
who was uh who was soliciting children
and they didn't want to prosecute him
because they were worried about state
secrets and then of course the very
obvious elephant in the room epstein
which has not yet been resolved but
everyone knows and so the issue i have
is it's really fascinating to me that if
you follow the establishment they'll
tell you there's a conspiracy theory
that powerful elites are abusing
children and trafficking them and sure
yeah some of it is out there crazy
conspiracy stuff like you know vampiric
global elites are like exsanguinating
babies to like live forever or something
which is a gross exaggeration of people
who do get blood transfusions to try and
increase their health or whatever but
the reality is more and more stories are
coming about high-ranking media
establishment elites who are abusing and
that's not committing atrocities against
children that's called atrocities world
chipper all of them yep no yep no no no
well you're not pro wood chipper i'm not
no we got gotta lock them up we gotta
lock them up
man this has been going on not even just
a little wood chipper
it's like it's like okay
when you get into a massive amount of
power do you go crazy because you're
like i am now in control of the slave
ship i decide who lives and dies i'm
insane now so they tend towards this
behavior like what these people are
doing to kids or yeah or is it that
those people
or i mean it's not natural it's not
natural to do that it seems
i don't know man you studied history of
like humanity like girls were getting
married when they were 12 10 1 000 years
ago a lot of people gain a lot of power
and a lot of money and a lot of it goes
to their head there's megalomania
there's people literally having god
complexes if you look at jeffrey epstein
he was into population control eugenics
like a lot of very powerful people are
now this kind of cnn cia connection
doing horrible things to children is is
not rare as of course there have been
many instances when this has been
happening with very powerful people uh
including a lot of people that are
connected to the royal family that were
doing similar actions that are
absolutely unspeakable and horrible we
have jimmy seville we have the prime
minister of the united kingdom
previously beforehand caught red-handed
doing unspeakable things mainline
celebrities but hold on i just want to
make this one final point here i'm not
going to i'm not going to stop your kind
of thought i'm just going to add one
thing there's a photo of epstein at the
queen's cottage yes but it's not just
that it's not just that it's not just
epstein and galen at
uh you know and there's also kevin
spacey uh hanging out at specific areas
that only the queen's allowed to be in
so it's kevin spacey glenn maxwell
jeffrey epstein but there's also photos
of gelane maxwell pictured with jeff
zucker's wife jeff zucker is the the
chairman ceo of cnn and glenn maxwell is
pictured many times with his wife
there's also pictures of glenn maxwell
and the founder and the owner of the
atlantic the atlantic just wrote a piece
that was entitled the great fake child
uh blank expletive
um
the fake epidemic that's not happening
and they wrote an article about how this
is all not happening uh just recently
during the middle of the gelane maxwell
case which is absolutely absurd to say
the least and to see the owner of the
atlantic uh with galen maxwell to see
glenn maxwell with jeff zucker's wife to
see glenn maxwell with so many other
powerful people now it could be glenn
maxwell just storming in taking a photo
there i'm not here looking to to make
any judgments here correlation does not
prove causation but there sure is a lot
of coincidences there sure is a lot of
these very powerful people that do work
together that do have similar
actions that are unspeakable to children
that deserve to be called out for that
deserve to be held accountable for that
people deserve to be at least in prison
for the rest of their lives for the
horrible actions that they committed
against children and a lot of these
crimes are not persecuted a lot of these
crimes the people who did the horrible
things they're able to get away with
them and that to me is the biggest
injustice because in a lot of these
cases your tax dollars are paying for
the for these people's protection that's
absurd i have to say so i i'm never
gonna run for president
but if i did my main platform would be
wood chipper
we've gotta we've gotta lock people up
we've gotta lock them up forever more
people need to be imprisoned for a
longer amount of time and many other
people should not be imprisoned for
non-violent offenses i you know for
for people who commit crimes against
children
in that particular manner
prison's not good enough for them
prison's too good for you saying death
penalty
that's the only time
wood chipper
i'm just not i'm i'm just not i'm just
anti-death penalty man i mean no no
don't get me wrong i'm i'm anti-death
penalty too but for this group of people
but this particular one i'm making this
and you know the thing too is like i
really think the prison system doesn't
work but for people who abuse kids i
think we need a special place to lock
them up excuse me yeah a lot of times
like epstein island when people leave
prison i don't know if the numbers they
they enjoy that island so i'd rather oh
no i meant like it's only them though
maybe like the base of a volcano
maybe a place of a volcano it seems like
prison doesn't make people not pedo like
if someone's a child abuser they go to
jail it doesn't seem to make them not a
child abuser anymore like they get let
back out and i don't know what the
recidivism is exactly well they sure
face a lot of punishment a lot of people
who do hurt children when they do end up
in jail face a very very tough
circumstances by other prisoners who
make sure that they face the full
ramifications for their crimes and
atrocities now the problem is there's
there's other people who are falsely
accused so you know that brings up a
very interesting you know question and
dynamic to to everything but when people
who do hurt children go to jail they
have one of the worst times imaginable
the stories that come out of people who
do that are um are absolutely crazy and
we and look like i said even the most
heinous crimes the cnn producer
still innocent until proven guilty right
then and yes the uh extenuating you know
i believe in our justice system i
believe that you know forensic evidence
will prove
guilt
or innocence
well you never pros and prove in a sense
well i'm sorry they are always apologies
that's right misspoke proves guilt do
you support the death penalty luke um
it's it's something that i haven't um
come to a conclusion on it's very hard
to make that kind of um
that kind of call based on each
circumstance based on the situation it's
hard to just generalize that kind of
concept and idea because
um
it's something that i need more time to
i have to say and study part of me was
trolling a little bit because yes i am
actually very anti-death penalty i mean
for example i don't think the state
should have the right to kill somebody
oh for sure you don't give that power to
the state it's actually
you're letting him play god there there
i should very very much clarify that
statement right there are certain
circumstances war conflict um defense of
others obviously i just mean like
empowering the state to decide they can
end someone's life right i think we you
convict someone you go through due
process then you can you know
lock them up like on the real like i'm
definitely anti-death penalty and i'm
with you on that you know lock them up
and yeah never and and i think that as
you were saying luke yes
people who commit crimes against
children they definitely have the worst
experience in prison so i'm perfectly
okay with that
but you know what chipper i think i tend
to support the death penalty my whole
life i've supported the death penalty
but
i mean
why why support the death penalty
because i think some people are so
deranged and damaged animals that they
are just a detriment to our species well
okay so let's do a vote right now how
many of how many of you here think ian
is being a detriment to us and we should
have the right to end his life i think
we should take away his phone oh see
there you go so so look and that's my
segway today none of you will ever be
the point is my point is
to be an individual
to have your own life liberty pursuit of
happiness and then to have the majority
just to say we decide what morality is
and our morality dictates we as the
majority can vote for the end of your
life i say that that's just absolutely
incorrect i mean you can't do that
that's the history of our species and
that's wrong tossing people out and
that's wrong because what's going to
happen is you're going to get a bunch of
locusts who are going to be like you
said a hate speech off with his head
perfect speech what about when one guy's
like eating all the tribe's food and
you're like stop and he's like it's
called tying up his hands and being like
so you can't use your hands yeah and
he's like okay well so then you let him
go and he does it again so then you kick
him out of the tribe then he raises an
army and comes back and kills everyone
and takes the truth
that's ridiculous just because someone
is exiled doesn't mean they're gonna
raise an army that's what napoleon did
he got exiled and then when he came back
all those old generals joined him again
and then he sounds like his old generals
were friends with him yeah sounds like
he never lost his the support from the
front should the french have executed
him when they arrested him the first
time after he you know no
really you don't think so dude i don't
believe in the death penalty i think how
about if they didn't exile him and they
put him in in in the uh was the steel
they didn't want to martyr him so they
exiled him and they just locked him up
that they didn't want to martyr him they
thought that if they
so
what you're saying is that so what
you're saying is that osama bin laden is
still alive and that he's being held in
the cia
because the the united states did not
want to martyr him right yes
i believe yes
you know that's why they
that's why they
they followed strict uh islamic protocol
and dumped him into the water yeah right
which which obviously is never in any
kind of islamic script or understanding
i i i don't i don't even necessarily
agree with imprisonment with to a
certain extent like i think if the
community decides you are a threat or a
danger to others then exile is
the right way to do things the problem
is in in the modern world it's
impossible to do yeah yeah because
everything's controlled by somebody
there's an interest everywhere there's
there's tons of people so all they can
really do is say and we can't let you go
because no one else is going to be happy
if we do that so we're going to lock you
in a box forever and i'm like
i'm not a big fan
of
that you know of like 10 people saying
we believe you did x therefore we can
take away your life liberty of happiness
because those people often are wrong
they're they're more often correct like
a jury of your peers you know i think
for the most part our legal our judicial
system does a good job of protecting
innocents but a lot of innocent people
go to prison and
i i agree with uh you know ben frank the
founding father's view on
the right of the of this the accused to
be innocent they are innocent until
proven guilty in that
if people believe
that the state at any point without
reason can strip them of their rights
then they have no they have no reason to
believe and and
and and adhere to that system meaning if
it gets to a point where people are just
like why bother they could arrest me
anyway might as well shoplift right why
why bother playing by the rules if
they're not going to play by the rules
either and that's where we're going and
that's freaky to me we're at a point now
where we can see hillary clinton thirty
thousand emails deleted nothing happens
well yeah i mean we we're heading in
that direction already because
and again
the more information that we're exposed
to the more we understand that the game
is stacked against us or rigged
and
basically
we're you know it's a big club and you
ain't in it
we're not in it i'm thinking about all
that oil although tim you might be in it
i i don't know maybe what does it what
does it mean to be in the club
i don't know you tell me you're in the
club what does that mean
i don't think i'm in the club i think
just just like you get the same medical
treatment as congress does that nobody
knows about it that's what we'll talk
about yeah that could be one of them
well i'll put it this way there's a crab
there's a barrel full of crabs and i'm
the crab on top of that barrel trying to
climb its way out yeah and everybody's
you know you know you know crabs in a
barrel and yeah
i think you're in tier three club
there's a bunch of crabs outside the
barrel they're doing that crab dance
team
and then there's intention
congress and ceos and global elites and
all stuff yeah that's the tier two club
is like the elon musk and those people
and then the tier one clubs like davos
and uh i don't know
foreign relations yeah yeah yeah i would
i would agree that like elon musk is
powerful but i don't think he's davos
powerful you know what i mean he might
be the richest guy in the world that
doesn't mean a whole lot like it means
he's the richest guy in the world he can
buy a super yacht yeah but he's working
on he's working on ai technology he's
working on microchips inside of human
brains so he might be especially with
how much power technologically he
develops so it could change at any
moment he he has enriched himself a lot
recently and he made some very
interesting comments against the vaccine
mandates uh just a couple of moments ago
which i think are very important what
did he say so
do you want to are we going to talk
about that we're going to talk about the
list okay i was going to add one more
thing about the death penalty to us give
give some
agreement to ian because some people are
chatting some good points um one point
is the state does that have the right to
end someone's life in self-defense or in
defense of others as a person does as
well and there's an argument that
through due process the state has
determined for the safety of the
community this person cannot be you know
confined or held it's just too dangerous
and so thus this is you know how some
people justify the death penalty i i
don't agree because the the the risk of
the state to callously and incorrectly
execute the innocent is too great for me
to support a system in which the state
is authorized to end life dude in the
age of deep fakes like if someone gets
caught like committed uh accused of a
crime that they didn't commit but
there's a deep fake of them doing it
that's gonna be just terrifying oh man
and then you're gonna have but but it's
beyond that
you're gonna go to court and you're
gonna have a prosecutor stand up there
and say ladies and gentlemen of the jury
the defendant used hypertext markup
language through the hypertext transfer
protocol to gain access to information
that you would not be able to get access
to and the jury's gonna go
maximum sentence anybody understand what
i just said i said he's going to type in
a url i was going to type in a web
address but i witnessed this happen
to some degree in the trial of weave
back when he was being prosecuted
because someone he knew
entered a url and got an email address
and then he said let's send it to
journalists the feds prosecuted him on
this and it was hilarious to hear the
prosecutor explain during a sentencing
why he should be locked up forever
because he used hyper text markup
language through the hyper hypertext
transfer protocol to get access to
people's private information why should
he have the right to use his knowledge
and power against us and i was just like
bro he literally just told the court
that some dude typed in to google some
words
and now we should go to prison for it
and people regular people don't get this
yeah it's not even about defects it's
about
ex like we're beyond the point where a
regular person can understand every
system
you know what i mean yeah and when the
prosecutor is more focused on winning
the case than
justice that's a problem i mean imagine
facing off with state prosecutors like
bingor and kamala harris going against
you knowing that you're innocent and
still
arguing to keep you in jail or to punish
you for a crime that you didn't commit
and there have been innocent people that
have been sent to jail that didn't
commit any crimes and there also has
have been people who have been
sentenced to death and killed by the
state that were innocent and never
committed the crimes that they were told
to have committed so there's instances
of that as well that we need to
recognize and this is already without
the deep fake technology that you were
talking about ian let's talk about the
list yes oh yes siraj tell us what is
the list the list is a power ranking of
people who need their phones taken away
yeah started ranking well yeah that's
power ranking i mean it started off as a
power ranking
but it's uh usually a top 10 of people
who need their phones taken away based
on bad tweets and i do it weekly i do it
monday nights tonight oh it's monday
night oh yes so we're gonna do the top
10 yes people on twitter
we are doing a uh a
we are doing abbreviated version i
narrowed it to just 10 candidates this
week we're just going to debate the
order of which ones just because
you know
i can take up to like two hours doing
this on this i think you've got a list
here you got to get from this
starting from 10. yeah so this is the
top 10 list of the worst tweets of the
week of december 13th 2021. do you do
this on on on rumble or youtube yeah i
do rumble youtube and twitch because you
know top tens are huge on youtube
like people love top 10 lists where it's
like the top 10 whatever well i have a
feeling that youtube is a bit
islamophobic and they don't want to put
my stuff up there that explains it yeah
because if they weren't they would just
put you on the front page exactly yeah
that's right
it's wrong think yeah yeah yeah that
proves it yeah yeah all right we have
the list here all right do you want to
read it yeah well so here's the thing i
usually read it in a pakistani accent
because
my
family they are from pakistan so i can
read i read bloomberg they are coming in
number 10.
some of the advice on how to cope
with rising inflation includes
spend your paycheck right away
it sounds so wise we did and we did talk
about this one that is a very good tweet
to make the list wow
um i usually go into commentary so like
do you think this deserves recognition
ian luke absolutely they're absolutely
insane i was talking about this before i
even knew it was on the list because
it's it's a an absolute slap in the face
to anyone paying any uh attention to
reality now what if it said spend your
paycheck right away
on bitcoin that's what i'm saying that
i'd be like that's a good thing if
they're what they're saying is
spend it before it gets devalued on
something that's going to inflate in
value then okay but if it's spend it
hazardly on anything
you're going to love number nine we
should we should get uh we should get
like a clear plastic for the tv so i can
take a sharpie and write with
bitcoin yeah all right all right number
nine
[Laughter]
bitcoin surge a bone for white
nationalists
study
the funny thing is it's a boon for
everybody
exactly
why is it not white national well
because look they take they they take
the umbrella of everyone
and then within the umbrella of everyone
and there's a smaller umbrella of white
nationalists and that's the one that's
going to get clicks yeah
remember that ryan i think it was ryan
long that uh was making a skit about the
employees that work at vice and they
took
and they took uh reproductive toys and
they just started throwing it at the
board
i think ryan long did something similar
but i think it was someone else i don't
know someone who will tell me on the
internet but they took a male
reproductive organ toy and they like
literally threw it at a board filled
with a bunch of names and it stuck and
then they literally created their titles
out of it i think this is this was the
case of that ryan long's was where he
was like you have a bag of nouns and two
different nouns and he was like why
blank is bad for blank yeah and you
would just pull random one ones up and
then he would like the funny thing is he
would show actual articles titled that
so yes bitcoin search a boon for white
nationalists much in the same way that
bitcoin boone is a surge for quite
literally anyone who owns bitcoin yes
and they're pets
i was actually reading a chart the other
day that showed that bitcoin is actually
a huge boon for black people and
investors in every field and al
salvadorians
and has lifted a lot of people out of
poverty
yeah not racist enough
all right all right this is this is an
economics heavy list i'm usually not
used to this it's usually a lot more
unhinged but don't worry it gets worse
number eight we have paul krugman he say
he tweets
aside from priorities is this even true
is there any good reason to believe
that inflation hits low income
households especially hard
okay hold on hold on he's an economist
now he's obviously yeah go ahead tim no
it just reminds me of um the feature
realm episode where the judge
is um
he's judge whitey and he's like oh poor
people the only poor people i want to
hear about are the people who tend to my
pores the spa like that's that's what it
reminds me of yeah pretty much that's
accurate i mean krugman has just been
wrong on so many things everything it's
uh
i don't even know where to start with
this one the man has no shame he doesn't
so when i love this because
when bloomberg is like quick spend your
paycheck as soon as you can because of
inflation and then he's like is that
really hitting low-income households
especially hard it's like bro they're
literally telling them to dump their
money as fast as possible like that's
pretty much what he's saying is if money
is becoming less valuable than the
people that don't have any money aren't
being affected by it anyway
that's a good point
why are you worried about inflation
you don't care
no you don't have money so why are you
worried about the value of money
duh
it was so easy that makes sense number
seven
president biden
tweets uh
the united states basis that's when they
are due
that's why today i signed a bill to fast
track the process to raise our debt
limit and if you don't believe me you
shut the hell up your mouth
yeah
this is effectively the president of the
united states saying
we're in debt so i took out a new credit
card yeah i took a new new loan a new
line of credit yeah see the thing is you
know they don't like it they don't like
ponzi schemes
but they
they they like ponzi zoom you know what
i mean like they the government doesn't
want you doing it they want to do it but
that's literally what our economic
system is the federal reserve yeah
number six here we go
365
3448 children went missing in 2020 you
haven't heard a word from media about it
therein lies the problem oh i'm sorry
they're in lies what's the problem
i see what she did there
i'm so they're in
lies the problem but that's not why it's
less worth it yeah it should be that i
mean this is a thing this is a this is a
thing remember remember like a month or
two ago with uh the gabby petito case
and then you had joyrie going on msnbc
saying that this is a this is a missing
white woman syndrome
and
no one has talked about like missing
people of color since
it's in the same token here with lauren
bober wait you can there's nothing
stopping lauren
from talking about tweeting about
missing children she's saying the media
doesn't run these stories you know what
i mean no i know that yeah is that an
accurate number is that domestically or
internationally is that a world number
or the u.s number or is that even just a
made-up number
good question
is m lies a word no it's not no but like
my bigger question she's spitting right
there i like that
he's making up words like i do
i gotta say i gotta say i think this
should be lower on the list i think you
think it should be lower on the list
where you think where you think it
should be i don't know i like it's like
it's a weak point you know what i mean
you think like number 10 yeah yeah maybe
okay we can move it to number 10. yeah
it may be number 10. you know because
one of the things that really bothers me
about media criticism is they they go
like
x happened and i don't see the media
talking about it right and then it'll be
like 20 articles they just google search
it yeah no it's a lazy it's lazy
criticism for sure and uh that is on my
uh intern ben who is uh ben morsi
who is going to be fired for this ben
what have you done then you could go
follow him on twitter uh oh here we go
yeah yeah yeah yeah
any time it's time to say the next one
anytime but i'm gonna let you do the
honor okay i say it okay i see it
number five
the atlantic we saw across the united
states well-meaning citizens are raising
awareness about the child acts
trafficking pandemic epidemic that
doesn't exist
kate tiffany unpacks how an internet
conspiracy theory birthed a 21st century
more panic
now did the cnn and cia pay for this
particular piece of journalism or did a
child trafficking write this article
yeah what kind of rolling elite person
how much money did they drop to to cover
up their horrible antics when it comes
to hurting children in unspeakable ways
the real epstein is an underground
bunker bunker writing the story the real
epstein are the friends we made along
the way
but i was talking about this during the
broadcast as well uh so i'm happy that
made the list because it's really
incredulous to say the least and the
owner of the atlantic is seen
in a very weird bikini photo with galen
maxwell cuddling up to her so there's
that here's here's the issue
they say um
child trafficking epidemic
how do you define something when you're
when you're using a like a metaphor to
describe what it is right like i said
literally saying it's like an epidemic
of trafficking but what's the threshold
for that there's no cdc guidelines
is there like if a hundred thousand kids
it's officially an epidemic
because the question is if we get a
bunch of stories if we know what epstein
was doing if we know what the cnn
producer is accused of doing if we hear
these stories at the cia officer and we
know there are powerful elites doing
really messed up stuff with kids at what
point do you decide it's an epidemic yo
america is oding hard on child
trafficking
number four
it is terrible account i hate this one
but let's read
january 6 was biggest crime ever
perpetuated against united states in
nearly airway republican is complicit
but that's true
every republican
every republican um even the people that
registered after january 6th isn't it
but isn't it a crazy thing to believe
that like
january 6 had a bunch of
like a bunch of bumbling people walking
through open doors where the police
opened it for him
cops were being reprimanded because they
were taking selfies with people there
was that riot in the front where they
were fighting with police and all that
stuff and it's bad of course yeah the
biggest crime didn't the british burn
down the white house
wasn't the french
no the french british did in 1812 i
think uh 911 pearl harbor
oklahoma city yeah many such cases many
such cases yeah yeah
i mean quite literally any serial killer
yeah uh
jim crow
slavery the testia experiments yeah
that's one wow
mk ultra i mean there's just this oh
yeah yeah yeah january 6 wouldn't even
make any reasonable list of questions it
would not it wouldn't even make the top
10. yeah it won't make the top one
yeah
you know i could probably make i could
probably make a list of 100 crimes
against the united states that were
worse than january 6 very easily oh yeah
you want to make that list next time
we'll do that next time the horse crimes
because the united states ranked but
here's the funny thing it's like if you
go back through history there's going to
be like ransacking of orphanages there's
going to be like the burning down of
like government facilities there's going
to be like the bombing of a military
base how many how many military-based
bombings have happened over the past 20
years
like in the middle east you know oh yeah
middle east for sure i mean
yeah
tons i mean
yep can't even name them off the table
you'd have to go like non-wartime uh
tragedies against the united states why
it'd be too easy if you did war time too
we're just creating new lists out of the
list this is crazy
well this is a very common one they just
they just yeah they say things they
don't think you know yeah number three
stuart stevens now this guy is actually
lincoln project oh god
or at least he's part of that elk uh he
tweets to be more concerned about
inflation than a plot to end democracy
is pretty much a definition of the
choice made by many and pre dubbed out
to germany
that is that uh wow very astute stuart
stevens wow the insight here is
astounding
um
yeah yeah you think it's you think it's
appropriate
for the list yeah top three i don't know
about top three okay but i think the
midas touch one is like should be up
higher you think maybe flip them maybe
flip them okay i don't know he's pretty
unhinged there i mean
why so why why would you argue that this
is worse than the midas touch because
it's just like absolutely
like like low iq to like it's highest
degrees
remember when you were a kid and they
would be like you know are you pt you
ever hear that one from a little kid and
then like no matter what you say it's
like a stupid joke that kids say
like if you say no they say you're not
potty trained and you say yes he said
you're a pregnant teenager like
the stupidest child like that's that's
how i view this
it's like operating under an assumption
that like
he's decided something is happening
that's really really bad yeah like what
i mean is you know like no matter how
you view it he's going to imply the
worst possible thing is currently
occurring like there's no
uh he he he's he's his statement
assumes too much i guess yeah uh so
you'd think it shouldn't be top three
though no because look at this one
january 6 was the biggest crime i ever
perpetrated i mean i i'm kind of with
you on that i don't know maybe you're
right you know you know what you know
what i'm let's think about like poker
right so let's do this
uh midas touch says january 6 was the
biggest crime ever perpetrated against
the united states that's kind of like an
ace high you know what i mean like it's
one statement oh no no he added every
republican is complicit that's a pair of
aces okay but here let's go down here we
have a couple things he's saying
inflation isn't as bad there's a plot to
end democracy and he's comparing it to
world war ii germany we got three of a
kind yeah yep yep so i think it does
yeah i think it does make the right spot
all right that's fine
number two
daily mail online
thirty two thousand americans who think
they'll be life at christmas
we'll be dead by your side yes experts
that's a good one number one better be
pretty damn good because that's great
that's huge right there
all that's missing is and you may be one
of them yeah yeah
thank you thank you for the christmas
present daily mail
i really appreciate it
okay here we go number one nels covell
she spells it noel but it's actually now
she did it for that christmas thing
this is after the horrible horrible
tornadoes that
over the weekend in kentucky or
like over 64 people have died
so i'm not going to read this in the
pakistani accent i'll just read this in
my normal voice
she tweets out sorry kentucky maybe if
your two senators hadn't spent decades
blocking legislation to reduce climate
change you wouldn't be suffering from
climate disasters if it's any
consolation mcconnell and rand have
effed over all of us too well i i do got
to say she's correct because as we know
rand paul has been actively assisting
china with their pollution in you know
um and well america of course has been
wait
rand paul has no power over what china
is doing you're telling me so that's not
that's not the case
uh
yeah what what what so so um
rand paul and mitch mcconnell right have
been uh assistant they're the reasons
why the the tornadoes right right so
they're in charge of the weather
machines yes right well no what she's
saying basically is that you know rand
paul has been blocking uh legislation
against china right right
wait wait what oh she's talking about
america yeah oh she thinks we have
control over the other oh yes
oh you're talking about the
trichlorofluoromethane that's being
emitted from from china's factories in
the northeastern provinces of of the
country that has like the highest ozone
depletion factor yeah and also just like
the general carbon if you want to get
really simple
and so um the funny thing about this
whole climate change thing especially is
like uh the united states passes all
these bills all these laws locally uh
banning plastic straws banning plastic
bags and yet the pacific gyre and all
the garbage is still there why because
other countries yeah so if you're
concerned about climate change and
you're blaming rand paul
yeah you have no idea what you're
talking about yeah this this lady needs
her phone taken away immediately
scroll down if you scroll down lydia
you can see that she deleted that tweet
does she earn any kind of credit for
deleting it um
just more humiliation
i'm surprised we don't have democratic
politicians calling to defund tornadoes
with that same kind of logic it's now
it's absolutely insane to use the
tragedy that people are going through
right now for political brownie points i
mean that's just disgusting you know i i
miss the good old days when the public
warning was don't fire your gun at a
tornado to stop this [ __ ]
didn't donald trump talk about like
nuking like didn't he yeah he wanted to
nuke a hurricane he did once yeah well
he asked about i don't think he wanted
he was like if we nuke it will it do
anything and they were like trump like
the hurricane
it's as big as new york
looks like nothing's gonna happen he
watched too much sharknados baller
now i gotta say something i gotta say
something
i really i understand why you made nell
number one
because it combined like bad taste with
disrespect bad timing and just terrible
times political like exploitation
and it was a very serious you know
i want the daily mail one to be the
first because it it's these are good you
know i'm looking at all these things and
i kind of view it like like poker you
know what i mean like
so this this thirty two thousand
americans who think they'll be alive for
christmas will be dead and they did dead
in all caps i love that that's that's
that's the right method right yes by
years and expert warrants it just
combines so much
it's like almost a royal flush of bad
tweet you know what i mean yeah but
i feel like
when weighed against a sensitive and
devastating event like nell scavell's
that trumps
that so let's let's break this one down
you've got the kentucky tragedy yeah
you've got political exploitation
you've got climate change you've got a
dig at mitch mcconnell and and uh and
rand paul
and
she's including herself as a victim in
the uh uh yeah and also and also in the
beginning and also in the beginning she
starts off with sorry kentucky it's very
blase as if like
it's like you know like
you know sorry this all happened to you
but
it's like a royal flush yeah i think it
hits it i think it is
that is easily number one with a bullet
it's like someone that you then fire
into a tornado
this is the equivalent of like someone
in real life getting run over by a car
and then like a liberal lady walking
over be like it's all fossil fuel's
fault
and then like
call it an ambulance help and like nope
i'm sorry we got to burn more fossil
fuels to get that ambulance
there was that story where uh a guy
working in an amazon warehouse i guess
texted they're not letting us leave
[Music]
terrible i just got to say ladies and
gentlemen i don't you know whoever
whoever you work for if there's a
tornado coming
think about yourself first protect your
family if your boss is like you can't
leave yo tell your boss have a nice day
because i can go talk to the labor
department you know the labor board
after the tornado and we can deal with
this and you trying to you know play
some be some bs man
but how about we now um
go over the super chats
i'm just happy that we got that all done
in like less than 30 minutes that
usually takes me like two to two and a
half hours
yeah i i do uh wanna wanna make one
quick announcement let me see if i can
pull this up
as uh before we get into super chats
um i have i have a great news this has
actually been true for a while but i
didn't um
i didn't actually think much about it
until today uh nick who's part of the
castle crew he was like hey did you know
that you know tim cast is the 15th
highest super chatted show in the world
and i was like no that's that is that
true i knew i know it was during the
election but that to me like wasn't
surprising but actually the only
channels that are above us say from
maybe a couple exceptions are sexy anime
anime waifus
and they play minecraft and now you know
where all my money went to yeah well let
me just say um
sorry honey people said
the 401k went too well i'll say this
though i'm not here to compete with sexy
anime waifus
you know yeah and you can't but uh
surprisingly
there's no one above us who does a
regular show
so if we're actually talking about human
beings live talking about something
anything no matter what it is we get
more super chats than anyone else like
literally more than video game players
minecrafters pub g we are the top
and so i i checked and triple checked
this and yeah and then i actually found
out this is crazy
in terms of viewership we are the 12th
highest li uh viewer viewed show
on uh uh on the internet higher than so
tim you probably know by now this is a
stick-up
so there's a bunch of look at this we
got you know like uh pat mc
mcafee you've got tim the tat man a
bunch of people above us uh h3 just
below us and pub g mobile down i'm
bringing this up just say thank you to
everybody i didn't i didn't really think
about like the size of the show or what
this meant like being number 12 on
youtube is big and
um being the most super chatted show
dude you guys are making all this
possible and i really really appreciate
it and i also thought it was just really
funny because
now um all of your support gets to put
us on a list of all these sexy anime
waifus yeah but if you if you want to be
number one tim you got to put on
lingerie and play minecraft that's the
strategy you know you know what we were
thinking of doing is asmr android making
a sexy anime chicken waifu
and then have an automated minecraft but
we'll just have emote buttons on a
stream deck to where like when a creeper
comes the chicken goes like
and then like when the chicken you know
dies or loses something it goes
and then we just make a stream where
it's funny and it's like a gamer
i guess i don't know maybe what was the
last game you played the last game i
played
i play spelunky too like to an absurd
degree
uh i used to play world of warcraft a
lot um mostly a long time ago i played
hearthstone a lot i have a bunch of
magic the gathering cards i played
destiny a lot but only i haven't i
haven't been playing video games a whole
lot recently i mean i'm sure you're busy
yeah super busy but i do
you know get in spelunky too every so
often unlike a seat it runs finally so
now i can you know
play around with set you know you know
spelunky yeah kind of arcade game it's a
it's a roguelike it's super fun every
you know it's a procedurally generated
roguelike game you get a jet bag you fly
around you get a freeze blaster i'm
still playing gwent in witcher 3.
ah i didn't like witcher 3. i didn't i
tried playing it really yeah i was like
i didn't like it the first time around i
really liked it the second time you know
what really bummed me out as fallout 4.
really good game but they fallout three
was magic man i have to get into the
fallout games fallout 3 was a magical
experience i'm pretty basic i like call
of duty and battlefield so before you go
into the super chats i just have to one
once again tim thank you for having me
on to do the list i mean it wasn't it
wasn't obviously the like the craziest
list
but
given the topics that we've discussed
it's very prescient to have this i i i
you know just to keep it real what
happened was you know we all had a
company meeting and we are sweating
bullets panicking we were like
sriracha's going to put us all what did
we do
let's butter them up let's bring them on
the show
[Music]
well i am here and i can actually
physically take all of your phones no
yeah uh i saw someone mention they
didn't know i played hearthstone i play
it like all the time i play uh i play
usually just play the tavern brawl
though okay i used to actually play i
got um i think the highest rank i ever
got might have been like five or
something it's a long time ago
there's 25 ranks
but i can't remember i could be wrong
maybe five is a little too generous but
i used to be really into playing the
competitive tournament stuff and then
eventually i just got i'm over it i
don't got time to structure these decks
you know what really made me not want to
play hearthstone anymore do you know
what it is
no so it's the world of warcraft card
game okay whole lot of fun it's really
simple the reason i don't want to play
it is because you have to manually drag
to open booster packs to get cards and i
have like 900 or like a thousand
boosters
so like it's just
just a chore
it would take me like you would get
carpal tunnel 20 hours to get carpal
tunnel and so people say you can you can
just mash the space bar on a computer
and i'm like
yeah but man i'm not going to sit there
and just do it and then what happens is
i don't have enough cards to you can
craft rare cards certain ones you can
earn certain ones and so i do all of the
the solo quest stuff i earn like all the
the legendary stuff that you can get but
then i'm like look man i've got like a
thousand boosters
if i were to open them all i'd have all
these great cards could make a great
deck you can't buy cards so i'm not
gonna sit here and do work for this give
me a button where i can press give me
the cards yo if they allowed me to just
buy the cards i'd spend a ton of money
playing you might be able to get video
take gameplay footage of you opening
them and then just if you get a
legendary and you see like whoa i got an
idea
numbers only i got an idea what you know
those little bird things that like go
back and then go down remember homer
simpson yeah when he was president yeah
i'm gonna do that on the space bar
and he'll just like boop and let them
roll and and open all my packs i bet
just an hour video of you opening packs
would be great behind this i don't have
an hour behind the scenes
smashing the space
people would love to watch that and just
you talking about the cards and stuff on
the website yeah i think you'd be
surprised how many people would love
that
yeah probably maybe we need a gaming
channel let's read some super chats
we got all right we got a super chat
here i can't see your name because
youtube just blocks it for some reason
he says tim i got my howard springs
shirt today to add to my cast collection
i dig it step on snack is next keep them
coming smash the like and spin the ufo
so i was surprised we made the step on
snack and find out shirt with a cute
little snake on it now people are saying
they want uh they want toddler clothes
someone said we chatted yeah we have
that one right here and so we're like
okay like yeah a little baby clothes
step on second find out people were like
we want more colors we want women the
craziest thing is out of all of the
shirts we have this one sold in like a
month over 2000 shirts
that's crazy there's something special
about snack it's so cute well we
combined two memes that's why it was
funny you know and it worked it worked a
whole lot we have another new shirt it's
luke riding an eagle with a waving a
flag it says i tested positive for
freedom and he's flying flag it's not
it's not wrong correct yeah all right
let's see matt h says tim and saraj my
tweet dream came true merry christmas
all and merry christmas to you matt h
yes
camel of the mojave says insurrection
when people who don't push the narrative
are upset but just another day when at
the kavanaugh debacle dealing with
feminists doing the exact same things
and worse you dropped the mask
yeah but they didn't break into the
supreme court you know they were just
banging on the door trying to break in
right oh no they did get into one of the
congressional buildings remember
gen 6 no no no during the uh kavanaugh
hearings yeah oh it's all got into the
like the senate building and they're
like man they shut it down yeah but that
happened so often
i mean this is a pre-coveted yeah yeah
it was you know everybody you know it
was the real was the real insurrection
oh yeah don't say that all right
on your platform audrey uh
what like what what it what's true right
yeah yeah what do you mean it's an
actual no it's just like a
culmination of buzzwords though
too much
audrey yeah kovit took over our country
yeah i think it's basically yeah i agree
audrey danielle says philly just
announced vax pass for kids and adults
i'm phl organizer for lp mises caucus
we're protesting around new year's
parade let us know if you in philly or
know someone down to protest at lpmc
philly on twitter i am no longer in we
are no longer in the philly area and we
got out basically for this reason we
weren't in philly we were in the suburbs
but i was just like i think it was last
august we were we were trying to get a
bigger headquarters and then we and then
once covet happened and the lockdowns
were getting crazy and they were
actually telling us not to leave our
houses i was like dude get out of here
that's crazy no but it really was crazy
where we were we had a backyard that we
could win a mini ramp and we could skate
so i was like all right this is not so
bad we're not cooped up in a box but
they were like do not leave your house
unless you absolutely have to
and nobody was outside and so i was just
like let's just leave let's just get out
of here you see you know what's
happening in australia which is
obviously i know you've been talking
about it quite often and how terrible it
is
how much do you think how much money you
think claire lehman from colette is
making from the australian government to
be like oh everything's great none
no i think she's avoiding prison
do you think
well she's tweeting under duress yeah
absolutely but i don't think they went
to her and said claire you must do as
you're told i believe that she was just
like if i say the wrong thing they show
up to my house they say why are you
posting these things on social media
they shut her company down and then
she's destitute and then she finds
herself in a concentration camp in
australia they passed the law where the
authorities could come to your house
right literally take away your phone and
tweet and send out and alter messages on
social media as you
so
i want you to imagine what if what if
you know because everyone said claire
lehmann's lost her mind because she used
to be like intellectual dark web and
libertarian right what if she's just
like you know cuffed in a prison cell i
mean there's some like big fat
australian guy going i'm gonna tweet it
this year tim pool guy you're an idiot
and then and then claire's like no
you're besmirching my good name
couldn't be i mean that would explain a
lot yeah absolutely that's the only
explanation they have laws on the books
like that i mean i've tried to put her
on the list but it looks like the list
already got to her
i have a i have a friend who lives in
australia and
uh you know i was talking to her about
like you know how things going and she
just told me that it's an open-air
prison yeah
and i was just like turning to the roof
you know but she was like i went out to
the middle of nowhere to get away from
it there was another story about a woman
that haley hodgson woman she said she
was living where was she living at like
in sydney or melbourne or something
and she went to darwin to get into the
middle of nowhere to get away from all
the lockdown stuff and the cops came to
her house and were like we're taking you
without due process to a camp now
uh james lindsay posted this what is the
defining factor of a concentration camp
feature unit it is
when you are taken by government
authorities without due process
to a camp that is how they do that
that's how the holocaust museum defines
concentration camp interesting and
that's quite literally what they're
doing in australia those crazy
conspiracy theorists over the holocaust
museum you know what do they know about
concentration camps oh they must be
right about this one all right
all right
how do you say this rickra morrison
lemniscate says step on snack baby and
toddler clothes yes yes i actually
texted let's do it we're gonna get those
chaotix says when i see talk of civil
war in america it's talked as if it's
own it'll only be america's problem
who's to say the globalists won't call
in favors from other countries i don't
want my country fighting against
american freedom
um a lot of i can't remember who pointed
out it might have been jack murphy maybe
not that um in all of these conflicts
there's always there's always foreign
intervention the american revolution you
had foreign intervention you know
you the french come in and aid
you know and and that was
effectively the you know a revolt in the
colonies
the french come in assist the americans
americans are you know they win
china's going to be assisting the
blue-haired lgbtq liberal people in
major cities air-dropping them china
armed arm-in-arm with uh with antifa
yeah that's what tick-tock is christian
the based burrito says my friend is in
the air force and told and and told to
get supplies he told me the situation
with ukraine is far worse than the media
is telling us and said the u.s is on a
econ on the verge of an economic
collapse
i wouldn't be surprised looking looking
at that spike in inflation we knew that
when they kept printing money the bill
would come due the issue is people don't
realize there's a delayed reaction they
can print all the money then they spend
it but put imagine it like this
there's a lake a bunch of houses around
it and then someone drops in just like
you know
20 000 or 200 000 gallons of water into
it boom
the water doesn't instantly hit all the
houses the wave starts coming you can
see it coming
and then it hits your house so we're at
the point now where that inflation spike
is us looking at the wave off in the
distance going yo there's a tsunami
coming yeah so what do you do
well me
i got crypto
um you know buying equipment for the
business trying to expand and get as
much you know going on infrastructure
wise as possible as fast as i can
spending that paycheck as soon as i get
it but that's not a long-term solution
i think we have to i i don't know man
i'm not going to give anybody financial
advice on this one i'm just going to say
i got crypto i feel pretty comfortable i
got some silver some gold and some
crypto there's also a lot of movement of
military hardware near the ukrainian
border which is worrying that has just
happened within a few hours so
russian russian stuff yes
it's not looking too good yeah
rafik says chris wallace moves to cnn
next day cnn producer arrested one has
to wonder what motivated wallace to go
to cnn at this stage fox won't miss him
that's right they won't money money yep
how much do you guys know how much you
got offered i think someone commented
like this is one of the first instances
um again this is not me saying i saw
this online it was very harsh a very
harsh critique of him saying that this
is a first instance of a rat going
towards a sinking ship
i forgot who who tweeted that wow that's
a good one but they went after him
oh my god
sumner robertson says if interest rates
rise to five percent
fed would have to finance 1.5 trillion
with inflation at 14.9 using cpi prior
to baskin interest rates need to be at
twenty percent that would cost six
trillion dollars per year fed will
either default on debt or hyper in
flight oh i hope you are ready for this
man i uh uh
i was telling this story last year when
i when i went on amazon and i went to
buy a tablet for work
and it was like 500 bucks and i clicked
it and then i forgot to check out like
something happened i just left amazon
open i came back later and there was a
box that said like we've updated items
in your cart the price went up to like
637 or something
like in that span of time they raised
the price that much on electronics wow
and it was like a day or two or
something
oh yeah
yeah i don't think i don't think people
realize what it means when you have
this level of lying about you know the
economy
but i'll tell you these elites are like
they're they've already got their
bunkers in new zealand just watching a
documentary on the great depression i
was really really awestruck at how the
media of the time kept telling people
the economy's fine up until like the day
before the crash the crash was like a
two-week process too of people just
slowly selling off and selling off and
selling off and realizing this isn't
going to go back up and selling and
selling but man the media just lied the
whole time yep
and this immediately changed their
position after after it crashed
immediately this super chat was from
when ian mentioned wedding the bed
surprise mechanic says
all right public news choice says spend
everything borrow everything didn't tim
dillon make this mistake diddy is that a
reference something i have no idea we
need no idea
bruno bronoski says don't forget what
happened last time the republicans
believed all lives matter and the
democrats said no those aren't people
isn't that interesting mm-hmm
what was that like 2014 no no civil war
oh war uh slavery yeah sorry slavery
[Laughter]
wow you're on the list yeah
oh yeah sorry when you were developing
the list did it come from a time that
you yourself tweeted something out and
realized no no no no so well i mean for
the first month of the list i was always
on it i was it was a daily thing but
what started it was george conway quote
tweeting his wife kellyanne who is still
in the white house this is december
2019. so yeah the list is two years old
now it's entering its terrible twos
basically the this is during the trump
impeachment the first trump impeachment
inquiry and
kellyanne conway tweeted out something
along the lines of you know dunking out
joe biden saying uh you know we need
russia's help we need ukraine's help to
beat this guy and george conway quote
tweeted saying your boss apparently
thought so and at that point i was like
wow
dunking on your wife in public in the
public domain public forum not cool
you need i need to take your phone away
and that's that's just kind of how it
was all created we should do a skit
where it's like the victims of the list
have all had their phones taken away and
there's like a black market smuggling
ring bringing phones to them so
i i have a running bit every every
single time an account gets suspended
that has been on the list
i take credit for it yes so when trump
got axed by twitter
i was like the list works
all right unvaccinated soldier says luke
i'm bringing a bunch of your spicy merch
to new york on saturday wish me luck and
i'll see you in the gulag yeah i'll see
you in the gulags too won't be that bad
i mean uh we're in an open-air one uh
just it's not really but
hold on i was you know i was thinking
about it and i was like you know i'm
sitting here in good company and i was
just like
if the communists take over and well
gets entered the gulag it's gonna be a
good time with all our friends yeah
we'll be breaking rocks hey finally we
have a reunion
i think that's a great tagline you could
be the most popular person in the gulag
with the best political shirts.com on
you being the the talk of the gulag and
maybe i'll i'll finally be on time for
habibi power hour
so here's the good news
all of the fans of the show will be in
the gulag and all of the guests from
this show will be in the gulab yeah live
shows live tapings live shows yeah we
won't tape them you'll literally be
sitting in the live audience where we're
all wearing our jumpsuits after the 12
hours of breaking rocks we'll have tim
castaire will still be there and we'll
just be there super gaunt and like you
know skin and body and they could do
that thing that they did the occupy wall
street or the echo the
people's mic or like they tap on the
wall that's what they did in vietnam
if you ever wanted to attend a live
showing of the tim cast irl podcast just
go to your local gulag
just wait a few months and express the
wrong political thinking and by the way
thank you so much for uh supporting me
t-shirts are a great way to get the
message out especially when the messages
are being censored on big tech social
media platforms so thank you so much for
doing so all right jack attack says i've
become a constitutional libertarian i
don't care if you are black white indian
gay straight pan everyone should have
the ability to buy an m1 abrams vote for
the corpse of abe lincoln and be left
alone
yeah oh yeah pretty much yeah it was
funny when ian uh asked uh carrie lake
about whether not people can own nukes
or rocket launchers yeah because i was
like i i think they should right i think
they should be like the right to bear
arms that's a kind of a debate we've had
ongoing like at what level of armament
do you want people to have the right to
own
nuclear weapons nuclear arms no it's
about you you have a right yeah like the
constitution says arms nuclear arms our
arms i'm not comfortable giving citizens
nuclear weapons what doesn't matter what
you're comfortable with you're asking me
the muslim where would you
where would you cut off the explodature
of your armaments you're talking bombs
with muslims
so so here's my point second amendment
says the right to keep and bear arms
yeah i'm very pro second amendment
nuclear arms
look we're entering a slippery slope and
yeah it's easy no no hold on well
obviously the answer is yes but you know
then i'm gonna abuse it
or my people will abuse and they'd be
like no more no more nukes no not me not
ever when i had someone tweet at me and
they were like i said something about
you know gun rights and then these
people just don't know anything about
the the establishment left types they
live in wally world this guy tweets at
me and he's like oh oh yeah tim so
you're saying you're cool with the black
panthers marching around california
armed with with ar-15s and i said ab so
effing lutely and then he responded
based like did you think i was against
that dude
that's good yeah just like going uh you
know after the kylo ren house verdict
you had uh people who were protesting
the verdict and then you had
uh you had a i remember father dollar
duo
carrying uh open open carrying assault
rifles they're both black with with uh
chamber flags in them yes and
wait is that good i'm sorry chamber flag
chamber flags block the chamber so that
people can see it can't be uh armed oh
okay all right sorry you know i love
guns but i'm a leather it so yeah but
they were walking around with them yeah
and i you know that's great and i think
it was uh jenk yuger who said like if if
a black you know teenager went with a
gun and was being attacked and you think
the right wingers would defend him and
all of the right was like yeah but it
was the meme of like the the bearded
the chad
yes
all right like yeah yeah absolutely in
fact in fact they would become a star
even faster than kyle rennhaus and the
weird thing is kyle right now said he
did he supported black lives matter and
he was actually rendering aid to the
writers
this is this is true kyle writenow is on
video giving medical attention to the
writers themselves there's no reason for
them to have assumed he wasn't you know
they're assisting them just because he
was like guys don't be violent i've seen
liberals at riots be like please slow
down please stop don't do that it's
making us look bad so kyle rittenhouse
helping everybody rosenbaum created that
whole situation oh for sure for sure but
it but the issue is i wonder even if it
was a black teenager would they have
been like it was a it was a white
supremacist like they call you know a
candidate someone's a white supremacist
a black face for white supremacy
yeah larry elder
all right win some sears yeah the jaded
kriegsman says most crimes we need a
norwegian style system for with
preventing recidivism as the primary
goal for the most heinous crimes like
rape murder and treason get
russian-style prisons see black dolphin
no you know what i like i think they
have like a um murderer island in norway
or something they just put all the most
serious violent defenders on an island
and then said you know you're on your
own good luck and there's like cabins
and stuff and they get food but
apparently what's happened is they've
all kind of chilled out these very
violent serious criminals because they
have to focus on survival now
so they still aren't being left
completely destitute but i could be
wrong i read a story somewhere you know
online talking about how they decide to
put them on an island and it's like they
have to work for their own fire work for
their food and stuff and now it's like
kind of helpful it's like hunger games
except they don't give them weapons yeah
they make a fist fight
i mean anything can become a weapon
all right
patrick hoey says i was against the
death penalty until a criminal law case
in law school the two defendants were
found guilty of kidnapping a 10 year old
girl keeping her alive for a week as
they tortured with
tortured and you know committed
atrocities some animals need to be put
down
man
here's the issue i have if you come to
me
with definitive evidence
of guys being like this is what we this
is what they did like here's proof they
did it
and like it's it's it's beyond a
reasonable doubt it's beyond even a
factual question like literally
you watch it happen i'm like through due
process i can understand being like you
are too dangerous to keep locked up are
you are you saying when i think you're
saying temple but pro wood chipper no
to go to
to go to the senate
and try and kill the chancellor
because you think he's too dangerous to
be left alive
did not see that
no no but uh what i'll say is the when
you look at these when you look at these
cases and they're like here's what we
know they did this i'm like
yes i'm very much in favor of these
people facing the death penalty now
here's the problem
when it comes to me entering a courtroom
and there's two guys standing there in
chains and the prosecutor looks at me
and goes ah dare say these two men took
this young girl i'll be like i didn't
see it happen i dare you you want me to
kill those guys dude
look if i'm in a room and they're
walking towards a girl with a blowtorch
and i have a weapon i will defend that
child's life and i will use lethal force
to do so but if i'm sitting in a
courtroom and they're like sign off on
this paper that says we kill them i'll
be like you don't have to sign you don't
have to do any of the sentencing stuff
as a juror fortunately you would just
have to say if you think he did it or
not no then it's up to them when they
say the death penalty is on the table
for this crime you're saying you want me
to to sign off on a death penalty ruling
and the judge is going to say yes i'm
not going to give that to the state
because
look beyond a reasonable doubt doesn't
just mean there's a yes or no question
in a lot of court cases it could be like
someone committed a a very light crime
and it seems like they may have done it
like a dude had a you know had too much
pot on him or something and it's like
man the evidence does seem like he
probably did it but i'm not 100
convinced it's worth ruining his life
over so i'm gonna say not guilty then
there could be someone who's like found
standing over the body of a little girl
with a knife and i'm like
now this is a different question of
beyond a reasonable doubt because we've
got you know evidence that he probably
did it and so in this instance i'm like
you probably you know yeah released from
prison for the second time it's his and
he's found over the body of a girl
here's the second time a guy who's found
with too much pot they're gonna be like
you're gonna get six months in in jail
and i'm like the worst case scenarios if
i get this wrong the dude who's innocent
is gonna suffer it's my fault i don't
like that so i'd probably say not guilty
but if there was something i thought was
bad enough and he's gonna go to jail
he's not going to be killed if anything
you should be prosecuting the officers
who arrested that person with pot
by saying why didn't you ask him for any
i will say
right yes
you guys should watch the life of david
gale
awesome movie i guess people don't
really like it that much didn't really
get great ratings or whatever but
it's about a guy a a a school professor
is falsely accused of raping a student
and then finds himself for another issue
it destroys his life then he finds
himself on death row and there's a
mystery to unravel like you know what
happened but it's a really good movie
that involves a death penalty politics
you know false accusations and stuff i
thought it was a great movie kevin
spacey yeah he plays the the the the
professor accused of rape oh god
who did he study for that himself
he knew how to play that character uh
we're still good at it wasn't in
character
all right j-man bees says tim i'd love
to see you play hearthstone on stream it
would be a nice break from having to
cover the downfall of western
civilization i actually i told you i i
did have a few um rehearsal live streams
a few years ago i don't i think they're
gone now
but uh man back in the day back are they
on the
yeah i was on the team channel i was
just hanging out i was like every
channel is on board i've been watching a
lot of uh trump hearthstone and what's
his name cripperian criparian is that
his name yeah yeah yeah
what if trump became a gamer that'd be
great right
that would be amazing
he was actually really good at stuff
yeah like i'll take you on grand theft
auto five let's go
he'd be like could you imagine trump
playing magic the gathering he was like
a 12 year old boy no he's like i'll
counter it again noob no trump's old so
he'd be like i'm going to play the black
ladies
and then i'll play uh uh what are you
going to play a black screen
and then i'll play what you got to play
um
the uh forest right for the channel
fireball is it forest and lotus or is it
mountain lotus no you're going to
mountain and lotus mountain green from
lotus yeah and so then you do the lotus
i'll do the lotus for three green and
then i'll tap the mountain for one red
i'll use channel i use 19 live points
and then i'm going to cast fireball for
20. first turn win
little kids gonna be like those cards
are old and they're banned anyway
no they restricted you wrong learn the
rules
that's not actually a trump
impersonation that's me impersonating
sheamus
multiple layers
yeah all right so we read that one let's
see
uh we'll reach a couple more here a
couple more here what do we got
patrick giles says so tim a murderer
breaks into the house kills everyone
inside and you have a gun
and shot do you let him go or take his
life
okay wait so you're saying that
everyone's already like been like killed
and he's standing there incapacitated if
if that's the case yeah i would tie him
up and be like okay now the cops need to
come and deal with us
so you need to understand that too about
self-defense like
you're not gonna get get a like if
there's like a guy who breaks into a
house and like kills a family and then
trips and falls and hits his head and is
laying on the ground going
like he's like bleeding out and then you
walk over to him and go
self-defense yeah the government like
the cops and the prosecutors are going
to be like dude you you just walked up
the guy and killed him like that's
that's not self-defense you were not in
danger it's so interesting that if
someone's about to kill your four family
members you can kill them in
self-defense but if they already killed
your family members you can't kill them
anymore well that makes perfect sense
probably because over history
vin dick like vindication crimes have
been so proliferative
where people go retribution like days
later served cold you know retribution
someone someone said in the chat
self-defense is the death penalty tim
if you have someone who's in a steel
cage you can't leave there is no threat
to you or anyone else if someone's
trying to release him and maybe like you
know the joker shows up with a
helicopter and fires an rpg and blows
the prison up in there and that's a risk
then maybe you could be like they're too
dangerous or maybe if the chancellor is
the sith lord we've been looking for
maybe the justification being like we
have to do something but you see the
problem was if mace windu just went with
the proper channels then anakin would
not have betrayed the jedi council and
the senator could have been stopped by
the jedi council well he is the senate
remember right yeah yeah that that is
that is tough but you know what like the
the idea that you think you can go in
and take this judge jury executioner
upon yourself
is just i'm just not a fan of that i
don't think it works i don't think it
works if you've got someone who's
incapacitated and they can't harm
anybody because you locked them up and
they're subdued but they're they're
siphoning the system if they sit in
prison for their whole life they cost
well i don't know it's forty thousand
dollars a year or something to host a
producer it costs money to to use the
death penalty young people though it's
like a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars yeah so that's like three years
of prison what does it cost 40 grand for
a prisoner or something all right i
don't like all these people sitting in
there that are just gonna come out of
prison commit the crime of all the
people that i thought would be pro-death
penalty ian definitely didn't come
across
here's the problem rich how many
innocent people are you willing to kill
to enforce the death penalty ian
none
but i don't wanna innocent people get
convicted all the time not majority but
if one percent if point one percent this
is why we need minority reports would
you be okay let me say this let's say
point one percent of people convicted
are innocent let's say point zero one
all right
would you put ten thousand people
you know through uh lethal injection
knowing that one of those people is
innocent
damn man
okay so ten thousand
violent murderers that are like killing
children every time and they they and
they and they have mustaches they throw
they
kill again if you release me i'll be
honest yeah that's that there were 10
000 murders villains that were
destroying society and i had to kill one
another
no no i didn't say that i said put on
through the death penalty lethal
injection meaning they're in prison
already they're subdued they're detained
and they're in in the bars going release
me and i'll kill again and there's one
guy going stop please i'm innocent i
didn't kill those people don't kill me
please that's a tough one it's it's um
situational otto von bismarck said it is
better that ten innocent people suffer
than one guilty person escape i don't
like those odds
i don't like any of the odds i want you
to look into the eyes of the innocent
person and say i don't care if you're
innocent i'm going to kill you and that
is insane well the people that i am
really support death penalties like is
repeat offenders people that get out of
prison do the same violent crime go back
to prison come out again do the same
violent crime like
if if someone's innocent they're not
gonna be in that pattern because if
they're coming out of prison and then
committing the crime again they're not
innocent i want to read one more because
i do think it's a really great
conversation i think people make good
points but i want to counter them sarah
roberts says people who are found with
evidence guilty of atrocities against
children are the one case where i do
support the death penalty those are the
people that cannot be rehabilitated or
redeemed and i will say to a certain
extent like i would agree with that but
the problem is how will you ever know
the state is correct when they present
someone to you and say this person was
found doing x
it's
for me to to to say
you want me to believe beyond a
reasonable doubt this person did this
thing okay what's the ramifications if i
get it wrong you kill him um or like or
like what's ratification if i get a rock
i may kill an innocent person i'm not
going to be party to that yeah i can't
you can't take that risk especially with
uh state prosecutors like camille harris
out there absolutely not yeah especially
when you were called the written house
yeah i was just about to say without red
house no you you get prosecutors who are
not in it for justice they're in it for
a quota a career exactly
career advancement there's a real
argument that one of the prosecutors
tampered with evidence to try and
convict kyle rittenhouse and he was
looking at life in prison over this
imagine if these prosecutors were
willing to go even further with the
manipulation of evidence imagine if they
were trying to say your honor we want to
add the death penalty because we
uncovered audio right now saying he was
planning on doing it and that he was you
know and and he did a bunch of things
that pushed it too aggravated you know
whatever and they try to kill him
like dude we know kyle rittenhouse was
acting in self-defense because we had
seven different witnesses on the show we
watched all the videos and it was beyond
a reasonable doubt the the the problem
with uh in this scenario if we were
wrong about kyle and he really was this
cold-blooded murderer
well the worst case scenario is he's
going to go home and it probably will
never happen again because the scenario
we saw the information we had was he may
have gone to this riot but he doesn't
seem like even if it was you know if we
if we were wrong about it it's going to
happen again it was the circumstances
around it but we all we all believed
that we were correct it was in
self-defense and it was the prosecutors
did not care they didn't care they they
lie they manipulate they cheat they
steal
the police will lie to protect the state
they will lie to defend their own
departments they will lie defend their
partners
and a lot of people on the right woke up
watching kyle rittenhouse go through the
ringer because they were just like
the evidence was so clear the witnesses
were so clear the video of the dude
saying to shoot him the video of him
chasing and then what did they do they
come up with this bs evidence and they
say there he is pointing the gun and
it's like yo they are lying right if
this dude kylo renas could have gone to
prison for the rest of his life over
these lies there have been kamala harris
she knew she had evidence her office did
that someone in prison was innocent i
think on death row right luke was she
was the guy on death row i don't
remember we have to fact-check that one
but there was there was a number of
incidences i'll just i'll just put it
this way i'll just put it this way
i understand that people are saying if
you know
like you literally watch someone do it
you'd be like death penalty for you
but what if
kamala harris comes to you and she says
i'm telling you this guy was found with
the evidence
would you take her word for it and
execute that guy i'd say get out of my
face i'm not doing it so until i can
trust the state with definitive proof
for evidence there are some
circumstances that are like okay i get
it but for the most part i don't anyway
i don't want to go too long so we'll
we'll say this follow the show at tim
cast irl on all platforms smash the like
button go subscribe to this channel go
to timcast.com we're gonna have a
members only segment coming up around 11
or so p.m tonight as a member you are
helping support all of our work you can
follow me personally at timcats
basically everywhere follow me on insta
follow me on instagram suraj you got uh
social media want to shout out yeah uh
yeah habibi power hour wednesdays 9 pm
on rumble you can follow us on habibi
rose on twitter habibi underscore bros
follow me at surajayhashmi
and then as always we have a website
habibiebros.us you can check out some
cool merch we got thank you maihabibi uh
i appreciate it
and
i also have my own independent media
organization it's called we are change i
released a very interesting
unmotivational video on look
uncensored.com with a lot of hard truths
that people need to realize that people
could watch there and you could of
course watch my daily show on
youtube.com forward slash we are change
hope to see some of you guys there
thanks for having me i got some info on
the uh kamala harris going after this
guy kevin cooper was the name of the
prisoner 1983 murder case of kevin
cooper uh cooper came with an hours of
execution she didn't want to allow dna
testing to get him exonerated but she
she tried to kill that guy that's wild
she tried to kill an innocent man i want
to say real quick sorry just because
there's two things uh super chats john
hoyle says tim makes the false argument
that the innocent in prison are of
greater value than the innocent victims
of crime and society it doesn't matter
if you are in prison
if you have not been convicted of a
crime you are innocent if you are in
society and someone attacks you you are
innocent i will not differentiate
between between the murderers i don't
care if it's the state committing the
murder or a psychopathic serial killer
coming the murder murdering the innocent
is wrong
so
i think the issue people have is they're
operating under the assumption that the
person in the prison is guilty and that
they are psychic and have enough
knowledge and ego to know definitively
or
that they say
i don't care if there is a chance he's
innocent if there is a one i i can't i
can't do it if there's a one percent
chance this person's innocent that means
out of a hundred executions you would be
killing one innocent person
i'm not i'm not gonna be standing at the
pearly gates and when they look at me
and say now i understand you were
killing all these people what part of
thou shalt not kill did you not
understand like well but these were bad
people so it was in self-defense and
they're going to be like you know okay i
understand that but this guy was
innocent well i thought he was a bad guy
i was convinced he was a bad guy nah i'm
not playing that's not an excuse well
you're gonna have to follow me and
crossland.net for more
good plug catch you later
thank you guys for tuning in tonight for
this really fun episode going through
the list i always enjoyed it yes thank
you so much all for having me all the
takes are ridiculous and it's only
getting worse so i'm looking forward to
the burning of the empire yeah we gotta
do a 2021 rap because there are a lot of
bad ones
special yeah all of them hey whenever
you want to have 100 lists live i
usually do top 69.
and then is there like a 420 quick quick
shout out honorable mentions
i mean there's a lot of names that's a
lot
i i probably will have to hire some more
interns and then fire them 4.2 names all
right all right uh sorry it's been a
blast we're gonna go over to timcast.com
for that members only segment so go to
timcast.com be a member thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all there
you